This is Jocko podcast number one 48 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening,
20 November,
dear mister and Missus Richardson,
I regret that I must confirm my recent telegram in which you were informed that
your son,
Master Sergeant William J.
Richardson Infantry has been reported missing in action in Korea since two
November,
I know that added distress is caused by failure to receive any more information
or details.
Therefore,
I wish to assure you that at any time additional information is received,
it will be transmitted to you without delay.
The term missing in action is used only to indicate that the whereabouts or
status of an individual is not immediately known.
Yeah,
it is not intended to convey the impression that the case is closed.
I wish to emphasize that every effort is exerted continuously to clear up the
status of our personnel under battle conditions.
This is a difficult task as you must readily realize.
Experience has shown that many persons reported missing in action are
subsequently reported as return to duty or being hospitalized for injuries
in order to relieve financial worry.
On the part of the dependence of military personnel being carried in a missing
in action status.
Congress enacted legislation legislation,
which continues the pay allowance and allotments of such persons until their
status is definitely established.
Permit me to extend to you my heartfelt sympathy during this period of
uncertainty.
Yeah.
Sincerely Yours,
Edward F with cell Major General US army.
So
obviously that is a letter from the government about a missing soldier,
this missing soldier in this case,
is it William Richardson and William Richardson or Bill Richardson,
who was a part of that whole melee that unfolded in the beginning of the Korean
War
when the eighth army was caught off from the rest of coalition forces and many
of those that got caught off as that retreat took place.
Many Americans and South Koreans as well were captured,
were killed or otherwise they were somehow lost or missing.
And this guy,
Bill Richardson,
was one of those men,
one of those men that went missing and clearly from this letter,
his parents were notified about that and he wrote a book on these experiences
that he went through.
The book is called valleys of death,
a memoir of the Korean War,
and you actually has that letter from the army too.
His parents inside the book,
which is a pretty shocking thing to see.
And you know these days the with with the current way they notify,
they send people to your house.
But I can't even imagine that the old days when you just get a telegram or a
letter that shows up and says that your,
your son's been missing for three weeks or four weeks or whatever the case may
be.
But this book,
I definitely,
there's the combat in this book is out a hand and you're going to see that
pretty quick.
And like every other book that we review on here,
obviously I can't read the whole thing,
but definitely this book is worth getting valleys of death,
a memoir of the Korean War written by Colonel William or Bill Richardson.
And it's a phenomenal book.
So with that,
let's dive right into it.
He lays out a little bit of his perspective writing the book here in the,
in the preface of the book.
And here we go.
This is not a history of the Korean War.
It is a down dirty.
Look at some of the soldiers who five years before had experienced combat and
the Second World War.
It is the story of the men.
They would lead a new generation of courageous young soldiers in what would be
the last true infantry war.
The heroes of this story are the young man of the Third Battalion,
Eighth Cavalry Regiment,
and in particular the men of the weapons platoon of El Company.
Okay?
Most of them died.
The story is told through my own eyes.
I've made a strong attempt to avoid adding to the story what others have said or
what I have learned over the last 57 years,
but there are a few truths that are undeniable.
Korea was a war that neither the country nor the military was ready for and we
paid a high price for a lack of readiness.
The disaster at [inaudible] written about in this book was caused by a lapse of
leadership from the highest echelon down to the battalion level.
Mistakes we paid for with the blood of the most heroic
I have ever known.
And you know,
when we covered chesty puller,
he talked a lot about that,
a lot about the lack of readiness and if you remember the marine corps throwing
together battalions to try and get over there.
And that was the whole country that was doing this.
And in the beginning of this book it,
you know,
he talks about,
he kind of introduces the characters that he was with.
He talks about some of the training that they had been through.
He was part of a squad that fired the 57 they called it,
which is a recoilless rifle,
the m 18
to 57 millimeter recoilless rifle.
Basically it looks like a bazooka,
kind of your traditional,
if you're in your mind,
you picture the Bazooka.
That's sort of what it looks like.
And there's a bunch of different variations of the Bazooka and this is sort of
one of them.
And in this point when we pick up the book,
he's kind of gone through that and they actually are now heading on callow to
California on their way to war.
So you know,
he'd covers the kickoff of the war and what that was like and him kind of
getting back in the game.
And here we go.
They're heading to California to get on a ship to go to Korea for the war.
Back to the book,
there was a gravity to it.
We were on the doorstep of war.
We all knew it and want it to be disciplined because when the bullets started,
discipline could be the difference between life and death.
That is indeed true.
Continuing the war in Korea had reached a crisis level.
American and South Korean units were fighting for their lives.
They'd been swept from the 38th parallel and quickly forced out of soul.
The North Koreans swept south towards Pusan,
a port on the eastern tip of the Korean Peninsula.
Now our troops were making their last stand along the NAC tongue river in the
west and and align north of the taboo reaching east to the Sea of Japan and they
were heading on the US troop transport ship called the pope,
which had just been taken out of mothballs.
If you don't know this,
they take old old ships when they're not needed.
They put them up while they put them in a couple of places around the country,
but they put them up and they called it mothballs and then they just leave these
big old ships sitting there.
If they,
if they ever are needed again,
they can pull them out and kind of get them up to speed.
So that's what the pope was.
It was a vessel that was pulled out of mothballs and now was getting ready to
sail overseas and these guys get on and the head overseas and then back to the
book after eight days on bar onboard the ship word spread that we were getting
close to Japan.
We do another month of training before landing in Korea.
We crowded along the rail looking at the shore lights in the distance,
the water made the lights from the city look like stars.
It's Yokohama and we're headed right for it.
I heard a soldier say suddenly the ship started slowly turning to the starboard
and running south parallel to the shore.
Okay.
I didn't think much of it,
but the next morning we were informed that we were going straight to Korea.
There you go.
That's the way the military works.
Sometimes you're think you're going to go train for an extra month and you have
a little bit more time to prepare for combat and all of a sudden that time's
gone and you're going straight in straight into the combat scenario.
So that's why everyone out there in the military don't wait till tomorrow to
train.
It's not going to come or it may not come.
So they pull into this port and Pusan back the book,
the smell was unbearable.
The water around the dock dock at Pusan was black and slick with oil and sewage
to docs.
Up from where we were was a cattle holding area where and when they cleaned the
pens,
they just host everything into the water.
The pungent odor hate us.
As we approached the pier,
most of the guys stayed below out of the smell,
but I stayed on the deck mesmerized by the port.
The eighth army had established a perimeter to hold off the Koreans,
people,
the Korean people's Army,
until enough troops could arrive and organize a counter offensive set up in
August,
the perimeters western boundary boundary was formed mostly by the nok tongue
river.
The North Koreans crossed the knocked on river
and then he says,
I know one thing.
If you're defending a river and the enemy is on your side,
you're in trouble.
That evening,
after another dinner of sea rations,
I got the section together.
This is his,
his little section of troops that he's running.
He's in charge of I want,
and here's what he tells them.
I want everyone to check his gear one more time.
We're moving to an assembly area north of the taboo first thing in the morning
and take a moment to write home.
You never know when you'll get another chance.
And that's one of those things that,
okay,
that can be perhaps a pretty heavy statement when he's saying that.
And I'll,
I'll tell you when you're in that situation,
if you,
especially if you're young,
at least in my situation,
if someone would have told me that when I was 19 years old,
I would've been fired up.
And that's just the way it is.
Um,
yeah,
I guess.
Um,
some people think it's crazy to think that way,
but I'm telling you,
there's a whole group of human beings in the world that they have a little
genetic makeup that makes them want to go to war.
And so when you get told,
hey,
you know,
you write your last letter home,
you're actually pretty fired up about it again.
I know that sounds completely crazy.
And even thing is,
he was a little bit older.
So I think for him he had,
it had more gravity for him than it did for his boys.
The other thing is I think it's hard for them to have recognized,
even though they read in the news like how bad it was.
And we've heard this from other people too.
We've heard this from other people.
Like you always think it's not going to be you,
right?
Yeah.
It's not going to be me that gets,
that gets killed.
It's not going to be,
that's not going to happen to me.
So you have that little thing in your brain too.
We just think it won't happen to you.
So
you aren't that concerned about it.
And the other thing is like you're,
you,
you know,
you just got done what we just got done with world war two where all this heavy
combat,
and guess what?
We were back to back World War champions,
right?
America was back to back World War champion.
So how are we going to get into a worse situation on this little random little
Asian country,
little peninsula,
like this won't be a factor.
So you had to have that in your head a little bit.
Yeah.
To,
uh,
I don't think they recognized how serious the situation was even though they
were saying it.
My point is that even though you're getting told,
hey,
this is a dire situation and we're,
we're holding up a perimeter to try and wait for more troops to arrives so we
can actually do a counter offensive.
Even though you're here that you're like,
all right,
that's no big deal.
We'll handle it in my mind.
Again,
I'm trying,
I'm trying to transpose a 19 year old brain on this situation.
All right.
Going back to the book,
the trains to Tegu left just afternoon.
I heard a few cheers as the train picked up momentum,
so there you go.
I'm right,
right.
The train is heading to combat and what are the boys doing?
Their cheering,
the train lumbering down the track for a while and then stopped at a siding.
Word came back that we were near the assembly area but had to make way for a
hospital train,
headed self.
The train carrying the wounded stopped for a few moments and we could see the
soldiers inside.
[inaudible] bags hung next to litters.
Men with bandages,
arms,
legs,
and heads lined the cars,
the few walking wounded stared out the windows.
The wounded Americans had dark,
depressing eyes and a vacant stare.
A few of our guys tried to pass them cigarettes and candy from the window,
but they didn't react.
They just stared into space.
So there's your reality check.
That's what we're heading for and that's a little wake up call.
I doubt that the there was cheers when the plane,
when they're trained,
rolled north again and they go from trains.
Eventually they get off trains and next up is they're getting into some troop
transport.
And here we go back to the book.
As the trucks rumble forward,
we could see American troops moving south down the road.
They looked like ghosts,
frail with torn and dirty uniforms.
They're black eyes,
didn't even register as we passed.
They had the infantry men's thousand yard stare.
They were lost,
gone.
We were operating under Lieutenant General Walton h walkers standing order to
stand or die.
Walker.
The Eighth Army commander had issued the order in July before we arrived.
And here's,
here's the quote from,
from General Walker.
We are fighting a battle against time.
There will be no more retreating withdrawal or readjustment of the lines or any
other term you choose.
There is no line behind us to which we can retreat.
There will be no Dunkirk,
there will be no Bhutan.
A retreat to Pusan would be one of the greatest butchers in history.
We must fight until the end.
We will fight as a team.
If some of us must die,
we will die fighting together.
Yeah.
I want everybody to understand we are going to hold this line.
We are going to win.
Now.
That's it.
That's a heavy statement.
And if you know a little bit of the background about this Walker General Walker
was in World War One and World War II and now he's in Korea.
And you had MacArthur at the time who was in Japan,
who was basically saying,
hey look,
I don't care.
You're gonna hold the line.
Even though Walker was thinking,
Hey,
I need,
you know,
massive support.
I don't know if we can pull this off.
And the order came and he was like,
okay,
and you know,
I mean I talk about this.
If you're getting that command,
you know,
you can't come down and say,
well MacArthur is telling us that we got to,
but I don't think we can do it.
No.
He's like,
okay,
that's what we're going to do our best to do.
Now as you actually study what unfolded.
Eventually he held it as long as he could and then he started to tactically
retreat to the best of his ability and so he sort of compromised.
He didn't just,
they didn't,
didn't stand and get slaughtered.
So he eventually made a more organ,
the best organized retreat that he could,
but still the,
the eighth army was on the run.
If you remember this time,
this is when the marines were tr trying to hold the line as well.
So it was a very hard situation going back to the book,
thick,
black smoke,
Rosen,
a steady stream on the other side of the horizon.
I could see only a few of the squat huts,
but the valley and ridges had fixed scraggly bushes,
which made it very difficult to see any movement.
Suddenly,
artillery shells and mortar rounds crashed down around us.
We dove into ditches that line the road and waited for the barrage to end.
I wave to my section and got them together before we moved out toward the
outskirts of the village,
a smokey haze with a pungent smell of gunpowder hung over us.
As we started moving forward,
I could feel my heart beating and my breasts came quickly,
almost like I was running,
but it wasn't nerves.
It was adrenaline.
My body was on fire,
popping with energy back on the road on North Korean machine gun to our right
open fire.
I could see tracer rounds in almost slow motion dashing into the line of men
ahead of me.
The soldiers duct and dove out of the way as the rounds bit into the dirt around
them.
Time is a strange thing in combat.
Sometimes it moves so fast that you cannot believe it in and other times it is
moving so slowly that you could scream.
We dove into the dirt and pressed ourselves flat against the ground.
Maccabee Maccabee at this time,
as the company commander started moving the other platoons toward the guns while
my section part of the weapons platoon provided supporting fire.
So there you go.
They set up a little cover and move.
This was real combat.
All of my fears seems so far away now.
I didn't have time to worry about how I'd react.
I just had to act.
Turning back towards Walsh's gun.
I yelled for him to get in position and start firing at the machine.
Guns.
Walsh nodded and started calling to his men like veterans.
They ignored the machine gun fire and got the gun up and got ready.
Put some fire on that hail.
I shouted,
pointing toward the North Korean gunners with my hand wash pointed out the
machine gun position and Gomez,
the assistant gunner loaded around and haul cited in the gun and fired my
section.
Fired it's first shot of the war.
So a couple key things that I liked about this paragraph of uh,
you know,
he talks about time and the weird things at time doe does during combat and that
happens during any really stressful situation where you become hyper sensitive
to what's happening in,
in the way it appears.
The way it feels is that time is actually slowing down.
I think the first time that I ever experienced that was in a car crash,
not a bad car crash,
but I was in a car crash and it seemed like things were moving in slow motion
and I wasn't driving,
I was just a passenger,
but I was,
that's the first time I ever felt it.
Um,
and then the other thing I'd,
so you can,
you can be expecting that,
be expecting if you're going into combat that you might have that slow motion
and it's actually an awesome thing because you can feel like you can,
I dunno,
to me it didn't feel like I was moving slow.
It always felt like things were moving slow and I could still,
it gave me more time to react.
It's like if you're doing Jujitsu and your opponent was moving in slow motion,
but even though you weren't,
even though you couldn't move faster than them,
you could see it and react to it properly.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
And then the other thing is if you notice the fear,
he's saying that he didn't have time to be afraid,
which is definitely something I've felt were like once rounds are being shot,
you're not thinking,
oh,
I'm going to get shot.
You're thinking,
okay,
we need to,
we need to get on mine.
We need to peel,
right?
We need to,
we need to make a call as opposed to,
and what did that that's based on in my opinion,
is training and if you train properly,
then you just react.
That just,
that's just what happens.
And this is why,
and you heard me say this at the,
at the muster,
when was talking about like from a self defense perspective,
for females that are doing Jujitsu for the first time,
I'm like,
Hey,
if you've never done Jujitsu before,
you're about to see that this is about as intimate as a sport or or this about
as intimate as an activity you can possibly engage in without actually taking it
to the next level,
right.
Without actually having yes.
Without being married to the other person.
Right.
So and,
and that's the thing.
If you get used to that,
you get used to somebody grinding on you,
get used to someone grabbing you.
And once you get used to it,
then you don't have to deal with that in the moment.
Cause you already know how to deal with it.
You can just react.
So it's the same thing here.
These guys have trained really hard.
And so now once the situation is unfolding,
what they're doing is just reacting to it as they should.
They're not sitting there panicking and getting,
getting shared.
Not that everyone's going to be like that because you will have some people that
will immediately get that,
that fight or flight and they might roll into the flight scenario of getting
down in hiding.
And so you might have to deal with that a little bit,
um,
but be ready for any of those reactions.
So now the first,
once they get through this first big kind of firefight going on,
now we're going back to the book the guys were digging in.
I told them to set up the guns,
but we'd be covering our section with rifles that night.
We were all wired after our first fire fight and it was good that we had
something to do.
I was happy to see that every bone,
everybody was digging in with a sense of urgency.
I was worried about our open flank to the right.
I ordered the section to dig in some positions facing to the right in case we
had to occupy them.
When we were done,
I told my guys to eat and rest while they got with Walsh and gray
word is the North Koreans were attacking that night.
So
the most of the,
you'll see throughout this book that the North Koreans and then eventually the
Chinese,
they do their attacks during the night.
That's what they do.
And that's how they roll.
They're there on,
if you remember even t Fred Harvey was talking about when he was doing the
island happy hopping and campaign.
They was Americans moving in the day and then at night the Japanese would
attack.
So similar situation here now it's actually the opposite against the enemy
because we have,
you know,
we have night vision capabilities,
we have a huge advantage at night.
So that's when we normally work in and,
and,
and in the seal teams.
That's the way,
that's the way we always worked.
We always worked at night.
Now when we got to Ramadi and it was a lot of daytime fighting.
We had to fight in the day.
But the preferred thing is to fight at night.
And that goes back to the seals in Vietnam.
And if you remember Roger Hayden,
I think it was Roger Hayden was saying when they were going out at night,
no one else was going out at night.
It was just like seals and going out at night.
But other than that,
it was only the Vietcong that were going out at night and the Nva who's but
friendly forces just just seals.
And I know there's other,
there's other ones,
but he was saying early on it was them.
So now the attack comes here.
We go back to the book.
The attack started with a guttural scream.
The North Koreans came out of the brush in waves.
We could see them moving toward us like shadows.
Muzzle flashes exploded out of the darkness.
There was very little aimed fire.
Instead we were firing straight ahead and into their assigned to zones.
Soon screams came from our wounded,
joined the chorus of battle cries orders and machine guns illuminating rounds
from our mortar section soon lit up the area like a ballpark making the North
Korean soldiers look like silhouettes on a firing range.
We dropped several before the flare burned out.
Since the rounds were in short supply,
the mortars waited several minutes between rounds during a lull.
I could hear one of the engineers to our left screaming in pain and calling for
his mother.
His saabs and screams for help landed harder than the North Korean artillery
shells.
Finally,
Private Jones,
one of my young smart asses,
had heard enough.
He started to yell and scream.
I covered Walsh as he scrambled out to Jones.
He was on the bottom of halls.
Whole crying walls,
tried to get him up,
but he wouldn't move.
I climbed out and helped.
Waltzed dragged Jones his ass out of the foxhole.
You stay with hall.
I told Walsh snatching Jones by his shirt color.
I stumbled with him back to my foxhole.
He crawled in and huddled against the wall sobbing.
He couldn't talk.
Even when I asked him a simple question.
His body heaved with every sob.
The engineer had finally stopped screaming and now in an ever desperate voice,
pleaded for someone to come get him.
Stay in your holes.
I barked.
I was sure the North Koreans were lying in wait,
hoping someone would try and get him.
God,
I wished he would just die.
That fought,
sent a jolt through me.
Jesus Christ.
I didn't really mean that,
that poor son of a bitch.
Okay.
My only thought now was pleased.
God bring the daylight soon.
I mean the sun's rays finally peaked over the horizon.
We started getting the wounded off the hill.
So there you go.
Like I said,
there's some people that are not gonna react well and,
and you got this kid Jones that can't handle this situation and he's done.
He's done.
What does this night too,
he's done and I mean obviously it doesn't help when you got to one of your
wound,
you guys out just ahead of you and he's screaming for help and crying for help
and you can't do anything.
And the order from Richardson,
which is,
you know,
stay in your halls.
And again,
this is the same exact thing.
The Ti Fred Harvey talked about when they'd captured one of his guys and they,
the Japanese sat and tortured him.
It sounded like 30 40 meters away.
They tortured this guy the whole night and the whole night t Fred Harvey's,
you know,
leaders were saying,
stay in your home,
stay in your holes,
were staying.
What?
What a what a nightmare.
That is.
Back to the book.
Walsh grabbed me and here's what says,
sarge black lost it.
He's crying.
He's hugging a tree and will not respond to me black.
I didn't know him very well.
He was one of the company's problem children.
He'd gotten drunk after a unit picnic at Fort Devins in the military.
Police had locked him up for being drunk and disorderly.
This incident confirmed that at w what I follow already,
black was going to be a constant problem.
I put them in Walsh's squad and we both kept on his ass making sure he was doing
the right thing.
When I got to black,
he was wrapped around a tree like a vine.
Every time a shell landed nearby,
he began shaking and crying.
No talking was going to help.
I just wanted to get him away from the rest of the men.
The section had fought well,
but after listening to the engineer all night,
they had their own nerves to continue to contend with.
Okay.
That made two men within 24 hours.
If this continued,
I would lose the whole section to fear instead of the enemy.
Yeah.
So two guys gone to,
you guys can't any,
and he's ends up sending him to the rear because he just can't,
he can't do anything with this guy.
And that's a tough call to make.
Hey,
if I send this guy to the rear,
how's that gonna Affect everyone else on the team?
Everyone else on the team who's going to be thinking,
you know,
oh,
all I need to do is cry and scream and I'll get,
I'll save my ass.
So you know,
in my opinion,
there's this,
if you're in these situations,
I think
if you're scared to die,
it's going to be a problem.
If you're scared to die,
If you basically accept the fact that you,
you could die and,
and you're okay with that,
that's how you,
that's to me,
that's a different screen.
These two guys and everyone else,
everyone else was like,
okay,
do they want to die?
I'm not saying they want to die,
but they recognize they can die and they're okay with it.
You know,
maybe,
okay,
was this a strong word?
They accept it,
I should say.
They accept it.
Whereas these two guys are scared and if you're scared to die,
then I think this is,
this is the kind of thing that happens because obviously if you're,
if you're like,
okay,
you know what,
there's a chance I could die and that's the way it is and I'm willing to take
that chance and I'm gonna do my best.
Like that's one attitude.
The other attitude is I don't want to die and here I am in a situation where
death is everywhere around me and that just closes it on your brain,
right?
That just closed in on your brain.
I can't like,
I can't imagine,
I can't imagine how that would,
how that would affect you psychologically if you are scared of scared of dying.
And again,
I don't want to,
I'm not trying to sound like,
Hey,
I want to die.
Or troops on the front line.
We're like,
yeah,
we don't care if we die.
No,
I'm not talking about that.
But to be able to psychologically say,
hey look,
I could die.
That's one of the possible outcomes here and okay,
I get it and I'm okay with that.
That's different than being,
I don't want to die out if you don't,
if your,
if your main goal is to not die and you're in a combat situation or especially a
really,
really violent hardcore combat situation like this,
this isn't gonna work out good for you
at all.
Yeah.
Because it's like when I,
you know,
when I used to work with MMA fighters,
if they were scared of getting knocked out,
yeah.
If that's what they were scared of,
it's really hard to not be,
to go into that cage with any level of confidence because you're scared of that
one thing that might happen.
It's the same thing here.
If you're so scared of that one thing happening,
that's going to possess your brain and even you yet MMA,
even if like you're,
I don't know if you're new to boxing or something,
you know,
and you,
if like you haven't accepted the fact that you're going to get hit every time,
like someone even flip,
you know,
if they throw a faint,
you're reacting to everything.
Right.
So if you're constantly under the kind of the stress.
Yeah,
the stress of like bullets and all this stuff.
It's like you're what we call it,
your self preservation
mechanism in your brain is just firing,
firing,
and then after a while that thing is just like gone haywire already.
Yeah,
it's gone into overdrive.
That's where it's happening to these guys,
man.
It's horrible.
It's horrible to see.
Yeah.
All right.
Back to the book.
The smoke and dust still hung in the air when they attacked again,
the first waves came with rifles behind them.
More soldiers followed and picked up the weapons left by the dead.
So that's a,
that's a common battle plan.
Where we're going to here is that we've heard it before in other books about the
Korean War.
Hey,
we're going to send the first wave.
They're going to have rifles and magazines.
The next wave is just going to come and pick up the dead guys gear and use that.
So part of the plan is the guy's dying garden.
The planning part of them.
That is absolutely part of the plant and not a small amount either because you
know when you,
when when the military,
when the u s military,
when he plan a big operation,
you plan for casualties and I can't say this about the seal teams.
The seal teams is like,
okay,
like we're going to take this amount of casualties.
The seal teams doesn't do that.
We're not planning to take any casualties,
but like you go with a big,
a big division going in for an airborne drop in World War II,
they were like,
okay,
10% of these folks are going to be injured on the drop.
Boom.
That's it.
So yeah,
and these guys are just saying,
hey,
we got whatever,
300 guys attacking,
we need about 70 guns or whatever that number is.
Back to the book on almost every attack.
The North Koreans tried to slip behind our lines and cut off our avenue of
retreat.
Once they did,
they would pound our flanks.
This time the North Korean soldiers charged up hill right into the teeth of our
machine guns.
After the third attempt,
they quit and we settled in for a tense night.
We waited all night but they didn't attack again.
North Koreans instead went around us and caught off the road back to Taboo Dong
as the fingers and the pink light shot up over the horizon.
We were ordered to withdraw through the Korean line.
This was not going to be easy.
So going back,
so they're getting called back,
hey,
there's a Korean line and they're getting told to fall back past that line.
They got it.
They basically,
they're kind of surrounded even at this point
and here we go.
He kind of expands on what it was like from his perspective and he's,
he talks a little bit about this,
just General Walton walkers mobile defense,
which was hey basically use a thin line of people to sort of sort of hold up the
enemy and then as like a screen and then the bulk of the force would be ready
for a counter attack.
And it was,
it was kind of considered a fury at this time,
but this is what they were trying to do.
And then he says,
for US ground troops,
it was confusing.
This game of chess would become maddening.
I never had a map and seldom knew the number designation of the hills or
objectives.
Now,
that's crazy.
That's freaking crazy and you've heard me say this,
the most important piece of information you can have on the battlefield as a
where you are,
if you don't even have a map and he's a section leader and doesn't have a map,
just Fyi,
like nowadays when we go out,
every single guy has a detailed battle map of the whole area of operations to
think that you have a section leader that doesn't even have a map that's,
that's crazy.
And then the number designations he talks about when you know,
you hear about hill three 48 or whatever,
he doesn't even know what those are.
Back to the book,
we only knew to move,
attack and defend unknown hills that would stop the North Koreans from breaking
through and capturing the city of taboo.
This was our world following orders,
fighting for one another,
being successful,
and somehow surviving.
Okay.
Now he there.
They're sort of in a little lull in the fighting in one of his guys comes over.
The guy's name is gray.
I'm not feeling very good.
I need to sit down for a few minutes.
Grace said his head was pounding and he felt dizzy.
Try to come over as soon as you can.
Are you going to be all right?
Yeah.
Just give me a few minutes.
When we got to the other side of the ridge,
I turned and looked back at grace sitting on a tree stump.
He had his head in his hands.
Now we know we know what this is a symbol of,
right?
This is a symbol of like a little bit of combat stress happening,
but he's just trying to get it together.
Grain Walsh had been great squad leaders and I hope he was okay.
I needed him to,
I needed him and his leadership.
I had taken off my helmet to wait to wipe away some sweat when gray and the
stump suddenly disappeared in a fireball and artillery round landed right on
him.
I was stunned and just stood on the ridge.
Looking at the smoking crater.
Something happens to men who see combat.
No matter how you try,
you cannot make death invisible.
It is there with you.
Every moment.
That split second would be seared into my mind for the rest of my life,
but at that time we didn't have time to mourn gray.
We had to get in,
start digging.
That round has us zeroed and the barrage will be coming next.
I said grabbing Walsh did haul over and take charge of grey squad.
Tell him I'll be over there to talk to him later
for the rest of the day.
I kept the men busy.
Anything to keep their minds off gray.
So let's think about that again.
You can see,
you can see that Richardson,
he's,
he's legit.
And this is your classic situation where this horrible thing,
you witnessed this horrible thing.
Everyone sees it and what does he say?
Hey look,
this is horrifying.
You say,
oh,
they have a zeroed in.
So where the ref next round is going to hit,
they're going to hit all around us.
So what we need to do is dig in and we needed to do it now and then he just
immediately say,
as hall,
go take over grey squad.
Look Grays gone.
We need to move on.
Tell him I'll be over to talk to him later.
Okay.
Back to the book.
What drove me more than anything was a positive outlook and the fact that my men
were watching everything I did,
I often wondered when we were moving down the road,
what went through their minds.
This is something that every leader should be thinking about all the time,
is that everyone's watching you,
your,
your boys are watching you and they're judging you.
As harsh as that sounds,
that's what's happening.
So you know what?
Give them a good example.
I'll tell you what,
when I see,
when I would see leaders in the seal teams that didn't act that way,
that didn't act as if they were being watched all the time.
They've,
they,
they usually slacked off.
Like,
what does that look like wearing?
Oh,
it looks like,
I mean,
yeah.
Like,
Hey,
oh no,
I can be a little bit late.
No one's watching.
Yeah.
That's a big one.
Like,
oh,
it's okay.
Oh,
I didn't need this piece of gear.
I'll cut the corner on this thing.
Just all those little tiny things and not to mention,
but when you're in a situation like this,
when they're watching you and you say,
Hey,
you know what?
They got us dialed in and we need to get Doug and now hall you got,
that's great squad.
Now get to it.
They're watching that too.
Yeah,
and they're seeing and going,
okay,
they're judging and what are they judging?
Their judging positive.
They're judging that Richardson's got his shit together and he's going to take
care of them.
Okay.
Back to the book.
It had to be a lot tougher on them.
The non me,
while they had only death dwell on,
I had dozens of other things that I must be thinking about and prepared for.
What was ahead?
Where would I be if I were a North Korean?
How would I react if we got hit from the right or left?
How was our ammunition?
Water was the bore sighting of the gun's still.
All right.
Where were the men?
Were the men taking care of their feet?
So he's saying this correctly.
So,
but this is a kind of a different twist is you know a lot of times you hear
leaders say,
well I was responsible for all these guys and that was a heavier weight.
But for him he's thinking I was busy with all these other things.
All these other guys had to do is think about the fact that they're about to die
and how that's actually harder on them.
Right?
Z You,
if you go into it with a perspective that everything's for you is harder and for
for everything,
you know,
for me it's harder cause I'm the leader where's his attitude is fantastic,
which is,
look I'm,
I have the luxury of having other things to think about these poor guys.
They're just thinking about,
you know,
them being overrun as opposed to if your attitude was flipped and you were,
you don't think I have it so hard but these guys have it so easy,
they will sense that and that's not going to end up net positive for you.
And you're in your leadership
back to the book.
The next North Korean assault started with screams and machine gun fire,
but we beat it back with mortars in our own machine gun fire running between
holes.
I made sure everybody was ready for the next wave.
Walsh had his section up and ready to fire halls all also ready,
which was impressive.
Impressive.
Since he had just taken over from gray.
The second attack was worse.
The North Koreans were less than 50 yards from us.
As I fired it,
the shadow is moving toward us.
I heard a frantic voice come over the radio.
Roy Rogers three the voice said in a deep southern draw,
I need more firepower.
I need more fire power.
I'm about to get overrun.
It was Lieutenant Jim Brown from the bell tune that was on our left,
I hope to hell he got more fire support.
We were all hanging by a thread.
Dead North Korean soldiers were stacking up in front of our fox holes,
but they kept coming.
Wave after wave,
I could hear Walsh screaming at the men to stay in their holes.
I was frantically changing the magazine in my car,
being as to the North Koreans were within 10 feet of me.
Walsh and hall saw them too,
and open fire cutting the North Korean soldiers down.
I saw another North Korean to my right and fired.
He staggered back and drop to the ground.
I stayed low and my foxhole and kept firing straight ahead.
Hall and Walsh kept firing to the rear,
hitting the North Koreans,
attempting to move through our position.
We had them in a crossfire and in minutes our position was littered with North
Korean bodies,
sliding a fresh magazine into my car being I poked my head up waiting for the
next wave,
but it never came.
Stay alert.
Some of them may still be alive if you,
if you see any movement,
shoot them.
We waited a few minutes and find the climbed out.
Okay,
check around your holes for live Koreans
and he goes on to say that we dragged the rest of the body's away from our
position and piled them to one side.
I didn't even look at their faces,
I didn't care.
And he talks about the fact that his medics would try and take care of the North
Korean wounded soldiers.
That's pretty impressive.
Back to the book.
As daylight peeked over its head over the hills,
a tall scrubby looking infantry man carrying a car being approached me from out
of the mist.
As he got closer,
I saw the small white cross painted on his helmet.
He stuck out his hand as he approached chaplain coupon.
He said,
given me a firm handshake.
Where are you from?
Chaplain Amil coupon from Pilsen.
Kansas was a catholic father who joined the army toward the end of World War II.
He served in Burma in India until May,
1946 he returned home and was assigned a parish in Kansas,
but he felt his calling was with the troops,
so he rejoined the army in 1948 he joined us in Korea.
After spending a few months in Japan,
his uniform was dirty and he like the rest of us needed a shave.
It was clear he'd spent the night up close to the fighting and not safely in the
rear.
There was a peacefulness about him though that put me at ease,
a quiet confidence.
He seemed to care where I was from and I watched him as he spoke to the rest of
this section.
Each time he asked a soldier where he was from and gave him a firm handshake.
It was not long before he had us all smiling.
When coupon finished making his rounds,
he sat down near my foxhole and took out his pipe.
It was missing most of it.
Stem.
What happened?
Your pipe?
I asked as he filled it,
a sniper.
He said,
shot it out of my mouth.
A few days ago,
we both had a laugh.
I noticed the car been laying across his lap.
I thought chaplains couldn't carry a weapons.
He smiled and nodded.
If they're going to shoot at me,
how I'm going to be ready to shoot back.
My section was down to eight men.
We received two replacements.
They showed up with their gear and clean uniforms.
One was named,
Jackson's one was named Jackson,
but I didn't catch the other's name.
Jackson had a lot of questions about the North Koreans and where we were on the
line.
Stay close to your foxhole partner and listened to him.
I said I didn't see them again until next morning we'd been attacked again.
But this time we were able to keep the North Koreans from our lines,
but not without cost.
Three men were gone,
one missing and two wounded,
including both the replacements.
We were taking casualties every night and soon could no longer hold our
position.
Later that night we got orders to withdraw withdrawing in the daylight.
Was it bad enough?
Now we're going to attempt it at night.
Yeah.
So couple things.
You're gonna hear a lot about this,
this chaplain coupon and,
well not a lot as you should.
Um,
there's the,
he's,
he's got his own story that needs to be told and about what he did in his
service
and then,
you know,
but I,
I tried to pull out a few sections about him and then the fact that these guys,
I mean,
they're losing guys all the time.
You get to replacements and they're,
they're gone by the next morning.
That's not a positive outlook on the situation.
So they finally get the orders to withdraw.
And it's funny,
not funny,
but it's interesting that they're actually not looking forward to withdrawing at
night.
You know?
Whereas me,
my instinct is like I'd rather go at night.
Right?
I mean of course.
But you know what,
if you haven't trained that way,
because you can train,
even without night vision,
you can train to operate at night.
You learned that spacing that you need to get,
you learn,
you know,
certain maneuvers that you do at nighttime that are easier at nighttime.
So nighttime is not something to be scared of.
But these guys,
unless you haven't trained that way,
if you haven't trained that way,
man,
I can't even imagine what it's like cause I trained so much in the dark.
I mean when I first got in the seal teams,
we did everything in the dark.
We'd have night vision.
No,
we just did.
We just patrolled in dark how we do.
We had closer spacing.
You learn how to use person silhouette in front of you.
You're,
you learn how to adapt your eyes to the dark.
So there's all these things that you can do to make you a more formidable night
fighter.
But if you don't train that way,
you,
you're,
you're in big trouble.
So these guys are starting up their withdraw back to the book.
Let's go.
I whispered.
I was nervous in wanting to get going before another attack while standing by
looked over at me.
Sarge,
that's Johnson.
He's dead.
So he was,
he was kicking a guy on the ground saying,
hey,
let's go.
And he's,
you know,
waltzes SARS.
That's Johnson.
He's dead.
I felt terrible.
It hurts to see another one of my men dead in the mud.
I didn't even know Johnson that well.
He was another replacement replacement and I'd only just learned his name.
The fact that I had a little time to dwell saved me.
Plus I knew that if I showed weakness,
my men might finally give in and feel sorry for themselves and I couldn't have
that.
We needed to stick together.
I became stoic and would remain that way for a long time.
Again,
he recognizes that his guys are looking at them.
There's two points there.
Number one,
he recognizes that his guys are looking at him and if he breaks down,
he's going to cause breakdowns.
And number two,
the fact that he had a little time to dwell.
So what does that mean?
Translate that to your life.
If something goes wrong and you decide you're going to take a break to reflect
on that thing,
it don't do that.
It's better.
That's like get back on the horse.
You know the old saying like you've got to get back on the horse.
That's not only does that help you overcome the fear,
but it's better than sitting around and dwelling on it.
You know?
Even if it's something not physical that you're physically afraid of,
still don't sit around and dwell.
That's a bad,
that's a bad thing.
Yeah.
Like are you saying need he gives you?
Like you,
something happens,
right?
Girl breaks up with you
and you take the day off from work.
When we get to sit down and look at the pillow that she necessarily
going to jam you up way more that you go to work and you know your mind's
occupied all these tasks and you know you don't have time to dwell.
And meanwhile I'll say this,
your mind is still processing it,
right?
It's not like,
it's not like you're at work and so you're not thinking about it.
It's in the back and it's getting worked through.
Your mind is doing its job,
kind of getting a grip on the situation and then you get home and like instead
of just going home,
go train,
go,
you'll go directly to the gym,
you're actually kind of stoke cause you're not,
have that pressure of your girl waiting on you at home to that kind of hurry up
and get home like no,
sorry.
We're trying to get some extra rounds and so go get some extra rounds and maybe
stop by that.
We'll place on the way home,
grab a little bite to eat,
you know with one of your buddies and then go home and when you get home,
clean your room.
You know when you get home,
just finished putting together the bid,
the bookcase or whatever,
do something and now you're tired and now you go to bed.
Meanwhile,
like I said in the background,
your mind's been processing this and you're starting to realize like,
you know what,
it's not actually that
big of a deal with that.
She left.
Yeah.
You know how it isn't there.
The,
I mean I wonder why this,
I'm sure he could kind of figure it out,
but you know how something like bad or traumatic or whatever will happen and
then the person essentially ignores it or whatever and focuses on work folks in
this book and then people close to home,
our therapist or whatever would be like,
hey,
I'm scared.
I'm concerned cause you haven't like,
yeah,
I think there's a dichotomy here.
I'm not talking about burying it,
right?
Yeah.
They're not what I'm talking about.
You still got to contend with it and you know,
at some point I'll write down like the,
the,
the protocol,
the breakup protocol straight up and the,
and even like the death protocol.
Like,
here's what you're supposed to do.
And now in,
in these situations,
they don't have time to do any protocol.
Right.
So,
so this,
to your point,
this can be a problem because if you're in combat and you lose someone and then
you never have the time to set aside and contend with it,
then you get back and now you get back to America and now your,
your family and now you're getting a new job and you're getting out of the
military and you're making,
all this stuff happened.
You never contended with what had occurred.
So yes you are correct.
If you don't ever content with it and face it,
then it can turn into a problem.
Then it turns into what we talked about with Tim Ferriss,
which is they tried,
if you tried to bury it,
you didn't realize it.
It was a seed.
So you gotta you gotta make sure that it's not a seed that's going to grow out
of control in the darkness over there.
You gotta you gotta put the shed some light on it.
Yeah.
Cause cause that's how,
right.
Like a lot of the time like,
Oh,
you know,
my girl broke up with,
I don't know,
whatever,
like something traumatic.
And then there'll be like,
hey,
I don't want to think about it.
I want to focus on these other things.
And they kind of
bury it seems like that could have happened.
And that's what I'm saying,
there's a balance that you have to do.
There's a balance because you can't just bury it.
You have to contend with it,
but you want to do it.
What you don't want to do is go overboard and just focus 100% on,
I can't believe that this person's gone.
Whether they died,
whether they broke up with you,
whether they would,
you know what?
I get little,
you know,
it's funny,
I get little warrior kid questions for the warrior kid podcasts of my friend is
moving away.
How can I not be sad?
And it's like the same thing.
Like people are gonna come in and out of your life and you got to learn to
contend with it.
And,
and what I'm saying is don't focus on it a hundred percent remember it,
contend with it,
but don't dwell on it because we know what that gets you.
It gets you just down the de,
the darkness,
the spiral of darkness,
which we don't want to go down.
No,
we don't want to avoid it because then it grows behind your back.
Yeah.
Well his situation's kind of different.
That's more of a small picture scenario where where it's like,
I don't have time to dwell on it,
guy who'd just,
this just happened to him because right now is the most important things going
on.
And I,
again,
this is where people get
jammed up because they never contend with it.
They never mourn properly.
They never go through that process.
And then they look up,
you know,
six months later and they go,
oh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm sad I missed my friend.
It's like,
yeah,
that's okay.
You know what you got to take.
That's why you should be able to take the protocol and just enacted when
there's,
you know like you get home from deployment,
it's like okay we're going through the protocol because we let we know or you
lose a friend,
car accident,
whatever,
whatever situation you want.
It comes time to enact that protocol.
Boom you,
you,
you press play on the protocol and then you go through the motions and that gets
you get you through it
or at least start to get you through it.
Cause there's always going to be there but it's not like you're going to be
like,
oh you're always going to remember but don't dwell.
I don't dwell.
Okay.
All right.
Going back to the book,
it was another attack and when I say that he's actually talking about there
being told that they are going to attack again and this is coming from his boss
Mccabe.
The entire battalion is going to attack hills.
Five 73 ridges go direct to the top of the hill.
Kay Company will be on the left.
We will move in the center and I company on the right.
We will attack at daylight with no artillery or air support.
The,
I don't like that,
like to know the second and third platoons will attack a breast.
Second on the right third on the left.
Richardson,
we'll follow with the 57 in the center.
The first platoon will be in reserve,
so there's your plan.
Boom.
There it is.
What does a breast mean?
Side by side.
Okay.
Yeah.
And now,
so they're,
they're sort of going through and,
and starting to enact this plan and as they're doing this,
one of his boys says,
Sarge,
we're getting out of here by dark.
Right.
Okay.
I knew the other men wouldn't speak up,
but I could just look in their eyes and see.
They were scared.
I just hope they couldn't see fear in my eyes.
We're staying here until we get orders.
I said finally answering Walsh and hall,
I spoke up loud enough for the whole section here.
Farther down the hill and mark mortar and artillery fire was heavy.
We could see the North Korean positions and they could see us.
I was hoping we were out of grenade range and too close to their,
to their position for them to put mortar fire on us.
Dude,
what kind of situation are you in when what you're hoping for is that you're too
far for grenade range and to close for mortars?
Wow.
Uh,
uh,
man.
So that just puts you in machine gun range basically,
unless you got some kind of dead space or cover,
but not a good situation.
But you know when that's what you're hoping for.
Outlook is not good.
That's your best sooner.
Soon instead of mortars,
the North Korean soldiers started sending down taunts.
We didn't speak the language,
but each word had a charge.
Silence.
No one talks back.
I whispered and put my finger to my lips.
Not that we knew what they were saying as the minutes and then hours ticked off.
I realized that slowly but surely we were moving back a foot at a time.
A guy would reposition and then the rest of the whole section would go off of
him.
At this rate,
we might be off the hill by the end of the war.
I knew one thing,
there was no way we were staying overnight.
So
situation happens.
Um,
they start,
they start actually there's a fire firing starts and these guys actually start
running down the hill and then they started receiving small arms fire and then
he rolls into another position and there's a guy in there named Vaillancourt who
was another,
uh,
experienced guy in charge of one of the other sections or one of the other
elements.
And he comes in,
where's the executive officer?
I asked Vaillancourt when I caught up with him,
he was killed along with one of the other platoon leaders.
The company has regrouped and tried to come back up the hill,
but it was ripped apart by heavy mortar and artillery fire.
We lost two lieutenants and two platoons took heavy losses.
So that's,
that continues.
And again,
you got to get this book so you can get these details.
I'm not reading them all.
There's the detailed combat for anyone that's in combat arms of any kind to
order this book immediately because there's so much good information in it that
I'm not covering.
So these guys,
they're retreating from that attack.
They get to like an orchard situation and there's a kernel that's in charge of
the regimen and this Guy Mccabe,
who's the company commander,
he comes up and here we go.
Maccabees kind of talking with and brings Richardson over.
Sergeant Richard,
Sergeant Richardson and his men were the last ones off the hill.
Macka B told Colonel Johnson how your men doing.
The colonel asked,
looking over my shoulder at the men finishing up their letter to Sears that this
little joke that they had made earlier.
Okay,
but very tired.
Johnson nodded and shook my hand.
Try and get some rest tonight.
He started to walk away frustrated with the attack.
I knew this was my chance to speak my mind and the mind of my men.
I wanted to know how many more times we are going to have to climb up a hill.
Only did leave it and fight our way up another.
From my point of view,
we were just getting our asses kicked.
How are we doing?
It seems like we never make any headway.
Johnson stopped sergeant.
You tell your men they did a great job against great odds.
We have stopped the North Koreans main attack.
I turned away and slowly walked back toward the men.
I thought to myself,
how Great Walsh Hall and Higley War,
it was their courage and bravery that held us together.
As I looked at them,
it almost brought tears to my eyes.
Johnson's news had an immediate impact on my section.
We no longer dragged ass.
Instead,
we seemed hopeful,
even optimistic.
So again,
this is a good point that when you're in a leadership position,
you're little words have significant impact and you might not realize it.
And I experienced that a lot with leaders,
not only in combat or in the military,
but I expressed,
I see that with leaders in the civilian sector where they don't realize the
weight that they carry.
And this will even be like the CEO of a company.
We'll,
we'll say something,
maybe it's off the cuff and it's a negative thing and it has a negative impact.
But they also don't realize how positive it can be when they say something
positive.
So if you're in a leadership position every once in a while,
every once in a while,
throw out some love to people.
Right.
I'm not saying you don't Lafe likes to use the word false cheerleading,
which is definitely,
yeah,
that's a,
that's a good term.
Yeah.
You know,
which is,
hey,
you've done a great job when you didn't do a great job and cheerleaders,
cheerleaders,
cheer,
pretty much no matter what.
Yeah.
This is what their job is.
They're cheering you.
Hey,
good job.
Even though you're down 47 to zero,
like they don't stop.
Right.
I don't think they just keep,
keep cheering,
keeps hearing.
So I guess you don't even have to say false cheerleader.
You'd just say straight cheerleading.
Well,
oh I guess when they are,
when somebody is winning this,
then it's positive,
right?
Yeah.
So,
Hey,
let me ask you this about false cheerleading.
So cause that came up in the muster by the way,
someone thought that it was just like focusing on the positives and not the
negatives.
Then they were like,
that's false cheerleading where they implied that that's what,
and leave it was like,
no,
false.
You're leading is when you're cheering for someone,
even though they're not doing it.
Yeah.
Or,
or making statements that are factually untrue.
Right.
Hey,
echo,
you did a great job putting out a bunch of videos this last year.
Oh,
that's actually factually untrue.
And I wouldn't be able to say that to you because you need to put out a limited
number of videos.
Yeah.
But if you were to say,
Hey,
those are real quality and not quantity,
like that would be factored you factually true too.
Yeah.
Actually technically that's an opinion.
But Hey,
the,
okay,
so what about this?
He was my question.
So if,
well let's say,
okay,
I'm doing like this,
um,
you know,
60% of my work load is great and then there's the 40 that's like,
hey,
you,
you got to change this.
And then I sorta sorta downplay the 40 ute.
It not me.
You like my boss downplay the 40 just to encourage me,
whatever reason.
Um,
and you really up play that
the 60 is that false cheerleading?
It is,
but there's a little bit more strategy behind this because as your leader,
I wouldn't only talk to you one time,
right?
I'm talking to you over a period of time.
So what my first comment to you might be something like,
Hey,
echo that 60% that you're over there,
you're crushing it out,
that you're doing a great job.
Super.
So you know some of the other stuff,
not quite there yet,
but actually the first time I talked to him I'd be like,
Hey,
you're,
you're crushing it.
You're doing awesome.
Yeah.
I might need to mention that 40% because I'm thinking,
Hey,
if this guy gets encouraged,
he's going to be like,
yeah,
I'm going to do a little bit more.
Right.
And yet that you just might pick up the sock anyways on your own accord because
you're just encouraged by the whole,
the whole positivity that I'm giving you.
Yeah.
So that's cool.
Right?
Well maybe it doesn't work.
So now I might have to come just a little bit more direct.
Right?
Hey,
I noticed that you know this 60% over here that you're dominating and it's
awesome.
Is there something that with this 40% over here that's different debt,
you know,
that date comes to cause it seems to be like a different level and it's not up
to 60%.
Is there something that's ever been,
maybe I find lard or something,
right?
But I give you the opposite to say,
well yeah,
it's because of this,
that whatever,
maybe we can correct it and then if that doesn't work then maybe you have to
amplify or escalate a little bit more.
Right?
And then it's,
hey man,
the 60% of that you're doing while awesome.
There's another,
there's also that 40% that when I'm looking at it,
I'm actually wondering if it's the same guy because for you to be able to do
this over here and still kind of throw this in the mix to kind of,
yeah,
it doesn't make sense to me.
And um,
again,
my whole thing would be trying to figure out why you're slacking in that area.
Because if you're doing 60% great,
why are you doing 40 minutes?
Let's hope there's a reason behind that.
And so once we find out what that reason is,
it's like,
okay.
And so I'm going to slowly escalate and start until I get to the point,
you know,
if we go six months and I've done,
I've pulled out whatever obstacles in your way.
Cause there was some obstacles on the 40% was like,
well we weren't getting that information at a time.
Okay Watch now I start getting you the information and tough.
And he said,
well I didn't have the resources.
Okay well then I throw you another person to help you and you're still slacking.
So eventually,
you know,
I'm going to have to come a little bit more direct and be less than man.
The 60% I appreciate the 40% is actually starting to hurt us.
And either you need to step it up,
which is what I'm hoping because I see nothing but potential and you or I'm
going to actually have to bring someone else in that can kind of handle a
hundred percent you see where I'm coming from and it would even escalated from
there.
So.
So,
yeah,
there's,
I don't think of things as black and white conversations like,
hey,
I just need to go in and drop the hammer today cause I don't,
I don't,
I'd rather,
I'd rather have you recognize it.
Right.
I'd rather have you realize that,
that there's a problem with that 40%.
Now I might say something and just omit the 40% like when I first talked to you,
and this is 60% of
this stuff we'll read that you're doing is awesome.
Yeah.
And I'm giving you the benefit of the doubt that you can straighten out that
other 40% right?
Get out your ruler and get it straight.
Syrah.
Of course the ruler.
But so,
okay,
so technically the ass,
so your whole campaign yeah.
Is not false cheerleading that.
So it's like,
but let's say you just stuck.
Let's say that for that first one,
that's step one,
right?
And then you've got,
let's say,
I don't know if I step,
so if you just stuck with step one,
I guess it depends on the reason to,
right?
So if I'm like,
Hey,
great,
this 60% is awesome and don't even mention the 40% because I don't want any
conflict with that guy,
or I'm scared to,
you know,
confront them or I'm scared for that.
That conversation as far as should be realistically scared of is if you're
doing,
if you're busting your ass to do that 60% great.
And all I come into say like,
Hey,
this 60% is good,
but the other 40% socks,
I discourage you and now you're like,
I can't do anything right for Jocko.
So now you're,
you're not going to get your 60% right.
There's a good chance that you don't even get the 60% now you're down to 50% and
then 40% is good and 60% is bad.
I don't want that.
I want you to be on board with the program.
I want you to be like,
Oh man,
I could work a little bit more and work a little bit harder,
discipline myself a little bit better,
and I could actually get 70% and then let's see what Jocko comes in here and
says when he's all fired up that I did 60% watch this.
Yeah.
So this is a whole thing.
So Dang,
you could almost say almost that false cheerleading,
I guess.
Okay.
I was going to say,
you could almost say false cheerleading.
Cheerleading actually has its little spot.
How does it in a bigger campaign used in a campaign,
but I guess technically if it is by its very nature,
if it's part of a big campaign,
it's not false cheerleading,
it's just this maybe strategics,
Cigi Maneuver,
strategic maneuver.
Like just think of a little kid.
I mean let's break it down to two.
The fundamental realities of life as a little kid.
If you take a little kid that does something,
okay,
let's say the kid tries to draw a rabbit.
Sure.
And was it look like I'm out.
It looks like doesn't even living up miles rarely looks like a stick.
So if you say,
okay,
I'm not going to overuse false cheerleading,
hey kid,
you're,
that doesn't look like a rabbit.
It looks like a stick fail.
Is that kid going to draw another rabbit?
It's not going to want to.
If you say,
oh,
I really liked that you tried,
I can see where the eyes should go.
You know what I mean?
And they get a little bit and they're like,
okay,
can I hang this up?
I'm going to hang this up on my refrigerator.
Huh?
Wait,
what does that kid want to do now?
Draw more.
Yeah.
Does that translate directly to adults?
Oh yes it does.
Does it always translate a hundred percent no,
of course not.
It doesn't translate 100% but because there's some people that are,
of course there's some people that just trying to skate and do the minimum.
And if you say like,
Hey,
good job.
You're like,
okay,
cool.
Thanks.
Right now I'm just gonna keep doing whatever you told me.
But if you're,
you know,
again,
for an EC strategic,
we're in a campaign,
we're trying to make things happen.
It's like,
yeah,
you know what?
Hmm.
Hey,
echo man.
That stuff fixed of the first time you ever made a video.
Yeah.
Imagine if I said,
you know,
I mean,
do decent work,
you know,
not exactly I grabbing though.
Would you have been excited to make more videos pro?
Yeah,
probably not.
Yeah.
I mean,
you'd probably be like,
oh,
okay,
well,
whatever.
I guess maybe this isn't for me or maybe I won't make videos for this guy,
but if I was like,
aw man,
I really liked the way that was some good that was,
you know what I mean?
Then you go,
oh yeah.
I'm like,
he's in the game with me.
[inaudible] we're a team.
We're not against each other,
so I'm just trying to unify things and bring things together.
Yeah.
I might even come back to you to improve myself more with deals.
I had the,
yeah,
we're a team now.
That's a good way to do my best leaders that I had.
All I wanted to do is do better for them.
They did and they never,
they might give me critique,
but it was like the kind of critique that makes you feel guilty about being
alive
with the alignment.
Really,
really like this.
You know?
I wish if we could do this a little bit more,
man,
that would be really nice.
I'm like,
man,
I wish I got better.
And then you have to also remember that people have different levels of
sensitivities.
Right?
Cause for you,
like especially when it's something that they deeply care about.
When you critique them,
there's almost no one that takes that critique.
Well,
right.
Oh,
you want to tell me about,
oh,
you want to tell me about whatever.
I did this drawing like a little kid.
Right?
The kid tries to do good drawing.
Yeah.
You tell him that the drawings no good.
That breaks their heart.
Yeah.
Yes,
it does evil.
Yeah,
man.
So you're right.
Is that false cheerleading?
No.
That's part of a campaign plan.
Is it good if the kid draws a stick and you're like,
that's the most amazing drawing I've ever seen.
Well.
Now what's this is to [inaudible] point,
if you,
the kid draws a stick and supposed to be a rabbit and you go,
that's the most amazing rabbit I've ever seen drawn.
Now let me ask you this.
Is that kid going to try and improve at all?
No,
and he'll probably not take criticism because they start getting used to like
never have.
Everything I do is great and I think that one applies more to adults because
when you say that to an adult like,
man,
that's the best thing I've ever seen.
They're like,
AH,
yeah,
they're a little bit more egotistical.
They believe it more.
Yeah.
Little kids are like,
well,
like kind of surprised if you tell him that it,
plus they wouldn't really believe you.
They're like,
hey look,
I'm only six,
but that's the stick as far as I'm concerned.
I'd tried to make a rabbit like I got,
I got an ear on there anyways after that.
Don't know.
I could see that too.
Yes,
so there you go.
Meanwhile,
back in Korea,
here's what's going on there.
Under another attack in his,
you can see there's a little pattern developing.
It's just we're
getting attacked.
We're getting attacked,
we're getting attacked,
we're getting attacked.
That's what's going on.
We could see the North Koreans pouring over the hill.
The North Korean artillery fire followed k company down the hill.
The ground shook like an earthquake.
As the rounds walk towards us,
I hugged the bottom of the side of the hole.
All I could think about was around landing straight on top of me.
If that happened,
I'd never know.
I pulled my helmet and gritted my teeth.
I was starting to lose it.
Okay.
Now again,
this is just continue there,
continue to get hammered and waltzed comes over.
He's are we going to stay goddammit to stay in these holes until I tell you
differently.
I raced back to my whole on the way a young lieutenant ran by me.
He was scared.
He was so scared.
As voice cracked.
When he screamed at me,
get Outta here.
Fall back.
Who the hell are you?
I barked.
There were men still trying to get back and if we left,
they wouldn't have a chance in hell.
So He's,
his group is trying to provide cover fire for the groups that are now
retreating.
He didn't stop and I never got his name.
He just yelled to fall back.
You're full of shit.
I yelled at him.
We can't leave here.
We have to help these men.
Yeah,
this is that.
He's keeping order.
In this retreat,
several other members of k company past me following the lieutenant,
I saw some of my men getting out of their holes.
You sons of bitches,
get back in your God damn holes.
I co I yelled,
get back.
They scrambled back round,
started to crash around us again.
I could hear the K company men scream is shrapnel showered,
them slicing into their skin,
larger pieces,
punched holes in their chest or sheered off their limbs.
Their screams filled in the silence between the crashes of artillery shells.
I was not going to be able to control this fucking situation much longer.
Walsh just stared at me with a vacant look.
Don't lose it.
Now I thought another barrage landed nearby.
I put my head down,
my ears started ringing.
Smoke was down on the bottom of the hole again.
The artillery fire finally stopped.
The screaming for the medics began.
Go check your man.
I told wall shaking him out of his stupor.
I headed over to halls position.
He had the same vacant look as Walsh men from k company.
We're moving down the ridge carrying the wounded.
Everybody was bleeding or bandaged.
I kept my men focused on the hill waiting for the North Koreans to counter
attack,
but they never came.
Neither did the artillery.
It wasn't long and I was told to withdraw off the hill.
He talks about the Korean augmentation to the U s army or Cat Catoosa program,
k a t u.
S a,
so Korean augmentation to the u s army and this was like soldiers.
He describes it here.
Katusa soldiers were young men picked up in larger cities given a couple of
weeks training and assigned to the American units.
Despite the language barriers,
the Koreans fell right in with the rest of us.
When we marched.
They kept up.
When we fought,
they stood their ground too.
Okay.
Over the next few days,
we continued to attack to the west.
It was a knockdown drag outs.
Slug fest.
The North Koreans attacked us with abandoned and tried to overwhelm us with
numbers.
They were fanatical.
One regimental commander said after the war that the North Koreans had no
consideration for the loss of life.
They have no hesitancy in losing 500 lives to gain a small piece of ground.
It took us three more days to take two more North Korean positions.
We uncovered large ammunition caches and killed 72 and captured 200 all at a
great price.
I lost two more men and the company suffered a total of four killed with 13
wounded.
The losses reduced our strength to round 53 men,
but the enemy was now on the run and we held the river river lined.
The morale went sky high,
so they kind of turned the tables a little bit as they went on the attack and
the counter offensive
and then they're continuing to push and as they're,
as they're heading down the road,
all of a sudden,
North Korean machine guns started spraying the road.
They had us in the open.
The North Koreans had us pin down and unable to push into the village,
which is what their,
what their objective was.
I heard the rumbling first peeking over the dyke.
I saw three Russian made t 34 tanks I could tell they were t 34 is because of
the narrow turret that sat on top of the almost pyramid shaped body.
The tanks had led the charge against Nazi Germany in world war two the t 34
dominated the German tanks because the Russian tanks could race over the deep
mud and snow of the eastern front.
After the war,
the Soviets sold them to their communist allies.
The North Korean invasion was spearheaded by t 34 tanks.
The North Korean lead tank was almost on us.
It stopped and the main gun started to slowly turn in our direction.
I looked at the road and saw a bazooka gunner jump out of the rice patty run to
the middle of the road,
stop shoulder the tube aiming at the tank.
I thought this guy must have nerves of steel.
It was a modern day,
David and Goliath.
Wham.
The rocket smashed into the tank and bounced off.
The God damn thing was a dud or the governor was too close in.
The rockets did not have time to arm a burst from the tanks.
Machine gun opened up and quickly cut the American gun down.
I scrambled down the muddy dykes screaming at Hiigli to get the his gun up
machine.
Gun rounds from the tanks.
Gunner sprayed me with mud.
Go for the treads I,
I watched he leads assistant gunner side around into the 57 on his shoulder and
tap them on the helmet.
I slid to a stop and buried my head in my hands.
I felt the concussion before I heard the round race by and hit the tank.
The armored tried to shake off the blast,
but when it moved,
I watched the tread roll off the wheels.
The turrets still worked and I could see it move back and forth searching for
targets,
staying out of the North Korean sites.
I emotion to Walsh to get his gun on the second tank in minutes.
I heard another blast from the 57 soon the two tanks unable to get there by
they're crippled mate reversed and headed back to the village
just taking out tanks with bazookas.
Unbelievable.
The next morning we started out toward the hill and the village,
a thick early morning fog hung low over the rice patties.
Visibility was zero.
We were stiff,
wet,
and very anxious.
As we started moving toward the objective up ahead,
I saw soldiers walked through the North Korean positions and continued toward
the village climbing like the last dyke.
We ran up on a road covered in North Korean bodies.
They were in a heap torn apart by shrapnel mules and broken,
broken equipment,
sat motionless nearby body parts were strewn on both sides of the road.
I saw men lying dead and still chained to the machine guns they were pulling.
As the fog lifted,
the site became even more gruesome.
Our our artillery had caught them trying to withdraw.
The same scene played over and over again.
As we moved up the road into the village,
we didn't face a fight taking this position
every mile we moved north,
my outlook changed.
The whole section looked and acted more self confident.
When we got into a fight,
we enjoyed it.
The killing was quickly becoming revenge rather than necessity rather than
necessity to gain ground and drive the North Koreans out.
We were still being killed only now we were the aggressors and they were dying
in their holes.
I knew we were better fighters and had held them under tremendous odds.
Now the tables were turned and they did not have the will or resolve to
accomplish what we had in Pusan during the darkest days of summer.
So the momentum's kind of changed and these guys are feeling,
feeling good about the whole situation as they,
and there's something good.
There's something that feels good about being an offense,
right?
Being an offense is,
is where we want to be.
We don't want to be on defense and this confidence can't continues as they
continue to advance.
Early.
The next morning we were back on foot advancing toward the North Koreans,
behind the three American tanks.
We were receiving heavy,
heavy artillery fire and tried to close to the tanks,
hoping the army root shield us from the shrapnel flying through the air.
One second,
I was looking back to make sure Walsh's squad was keeping up and the next I was
stunned.
A shell landed on the tank sending shrapnel and fire into the air.
The explosion was deafening and I stumbled back,
dazed,
falling down in the tracks behind the tank.
I saw the crew crawling out of the escape hatch machine.
Gun fire was kicking up dirt all around me as I hugged the ground.
Yeah,
I could see two tankers lying under the tank.
They were wounded and couldn't crawl away from the hulk.
Walsh,
I screamed,
help me get these guys.
A couple of artillery rounds.
Net landed on the road.
I felt a sharp hot pain in my left shoulder.
You all right?
Walsh asked as he raced to my side.
Yeah.
I said shaking my head,
trying to reassure him I didn't have time to worry about it.
The machine gun rounds pinged off the armor as I crawled underneath the tank and
grab one of the tankers by as color pain shot through my arm and my shoulder
felt hot and week I let go but hung on with my good hand.
Waltzed grabbed the other tanker and we dragged the pair intuitive nearby ditch
medic medic.
I screamed.
So this again,
there's this like heroism after heroism after heroism in this book and I brought
bring up some of them but I don't bring up all of them cause we just don't have,
I'm not going to read the whole book.
You got to buy the book
continuing.
I squatted down and try to take off my gear and jackets and the medic could get
to the wound because obviously got hit in the shoulder.
My left hand show cause I peeled off the shirt.
Now a few shades darker from the blood.
The medic arrived with Walsh.
He wiped away the blood with a wad of gauze and started to bandage the Gash.
It was on the backside of my shoulder and I couldn't see the wound.
A few pieces of shrapnel,
the medic said,
you can move it right.
Probably nothing torn or broken.
So now he's,
you know,
he's wounded,
not too severe.
Not exactly a good deal though.
You know,
you think about you,
you think about your neck in an athletic competition,
which is what this is.
And on top of that,
there's a massive amount of mental stress.
And on top of that you've got to make decisions.
And on top of that you get,
you get a big gash in your shoulder.
A couple of days later,
we were,
we sat overlooking the 38th parallel.
We'd push the North Koreans back now in a weighted orders to attack sitting in
my foxhole.
I watched as the full moon began to rise,
I got the feeling that there was something safe and secure as it washed gently
over us.
I felt like God was protecting us to,
we're surely trying to help.
At least he'd kept me alive.
Even though my shoulder throbbed if only we were back home,
we could all go to sleep under the moon's calming light and wake up safe to the
warmth of the sun.
Okay.
Now that shoulder wound that he kind of blew off actually isn't,
is not all that good.
He starts getting a little,
uh,
starts getting a little infection in.
It passes out from it.
I woke up this time,
they carried me back to the battalions aid station.
The medic set the stretcher on a dirt floor.
Doctor comes in,
you're lucky.
Had you waited any longer,
the infection would have spread.
Okay.
Some time goes by.
The next day I felt fine.
The doctors had me on a Jello Diet.
So when the doctor came on,
came on his rounds,
I told him I wanted to leave.
I need to go back to my unit.
I said,
typical fashion,
the uh,
of the,
uh,
American doughboy,
the American grunt,
they get wounded.
What do they want to do?
They want to go back.
They want to go back with their team and that's exactly what he,
what he does.
And a couple of days later,
he gets back with his unit and of course,
what are they doing?
They're going on attack and as they're going on attack back to the book,
all of a sudden there was a thunderous roar as an artillery barrage hit us.
I was blown straight up in the air.
My feet were over my head.
I came down on my shoulder and my head,
the mud soften the blow,
grabbing my helmet.
I yelled for my section to run forward out of the kill zone.
Three guys in front of me and two behind me were wounded.
I could hear them moaning as they clutch their stomachs and legs.
I checked myself.
I had escaped without a scratch.
Medics hurried to the down men.
I,
I looked back and Saki,
ugly standing days to get moving.
I yelled,
he looked at me with a funny expression on his face and then look down at his
waist.
He had been hit by shrapnel in the stomach.
I could see the blood soaking through his fatigues.
Um,
hit rich,
get down.
I said,
and I hollered medic.
He actually fell to his knees and rolled over onto his back.
I was torn.
I wanted to run to him,
but I had to keep the rest of the section moving.
It was one of those choices that you never want to make.
Yeah.
I saw the medics coming and turn to join the other men.
Good luck buddy.
See you later.
I screamed over my shoulder.
I couldn't look back,
but I knew I'd probably never see.
He Lee again.
A stomach wound.
I thought,
Jesus Christ,
I hope he makes it.
I wanted to sit down and cry,
but this was not the time or place for that.
I had damn near lost a whole squad.
There was only one way to go at the hill,
so now they're trying to take the hill.
There's only one way to go with the hill and it was straight forward.
I looked across the open space we were going to cross.
There was little cover.
This was going to be tough.
There was no time to dwell on Hiigli or are dwindling numbers.
The longer we sat behind the railroad embankment,
but tougher it would be to get started.
Bronzer was waiting to get artillery support.
The same guys I had dinner with.
I hope they remembered what I'd told them and come through leaning back against
the embankment.
I saw Alan and the Korean hosteling across the field,
each carrying Tupac boards with Ammo.
Get ready,
Brahms,
or said,
I grew up my rifle and closed my eyes.
My mind knew going forward was crazy,
but I willed my legs to move soon.
I was running and leading the rest of this section across the patties.
Mortar and artillery.
Fire crashed around me,
but I didn't notice.
I only saw the flashes of the North Korean machine guns ahead of me.
I stayed close to Mac.
I could hear him hollering at his squad to move to my right.
I saw that Walsh was right beside us.
He had his squad movie.
It all seemed almost normal.
It was just another day,
another attack.
So you're getting mortar and artillery fire crashing all around you,
but you're not paying attention to that because you're really paying attention
to the damn muzzle flashes from the Korean machine guns that are right in front
of you.
When they,
they,
they end up pulling off that attack and again get the books so you can get some
of those details.
When he attacks complete,
he writes,
I was not a religious person,
but I felt like one that day I gave thanks with Walsh for our gift of life
after services that evening we turned in our basic load of ammunition.
Another sure sign that it was over.
So just to rehash that last little statement,
they're turning in their ammunition because they're getting a positive feeling
like they've been doing this good fighting.
They'd been on a pursuit and they were kind of on the defensive in the beginning
and now they go back on the counter attack and now they're feeling pretty good
and now they,
they get,
Hey,
you know what?
You can turn in your ammunition.
Think about that.
But back to the book of that night,
we got orders to move,
but not home.
We were headed north to the town of Busan.
I was a corporal when we arrived in Korea.
Now less than 67 days later,
I was going to be a master sergeant.
The army's a highest noncommissioned officers ranked.
Okay.
The promotions couldn't have come at a better time with the war winding down.
I was sure this will be the last of the fast promotions.
So he's actually,
again,
these guys think that they're doing a good job and they kind of think that
things are heading in their direction.
And yeah,
1950 I mean,
we know just from history that this war is not even close to over yet,
and yeah,
but that's the way they're feeling.
And can you imagine,
I mean,
he's,
he's at the highest,
he's a,
he's a master sergeant right now.
67 days.
He got promoted through all the ranks.
That's how many guys,
that's how many guys were wounded or killed,
that they needed him to be promoted to run these units.
So they now get sent into a position where they're holding a bridge and while
they're holding this bridge,
he sends a couple of guys out on recon to take a look around and they'd come
back and he says,
what the Hell is that?
I asked him,
it's just an old glove and a shovel.
It's all wet.
It's probably been there for weeks.
He said in a defiant tone and that's one of the guys that were on the recon
talking.
That was on the recon talking.
It didn't look like any glove I had seen before.
It was large and padded.
What else did you find?
I shot back just some old positions.
Nothing to worry about.
I was a little concerned now and continued to quiz him on how many holes there
were up there around five or six.
The sergeant said was the dirt wet or dry?
God Damn it.
I don't know.
It was pitch black.
I'm telling you,
there's nothing up on that fucking hill.
The smug sergeant snapped at me.
You can guess what's coming.
You find a shovel up their guess what's going on?
They're digging in.
That's what's going on.
They're digging in and these gloves,
these kinds of heavy gloves,
um,
you know,
probably resupply from the Chinese cause that's why I didn't recognize him.
So they hadn't really encountered the Chinese yet that we're about to attack in
massive numbers.
Back to the book around 4:00 AM the hail erupted,
four machine guns from the high hills on the south end of the bridge opened up
two guns cross firing on each end of the bridge.
The tracers from the machine gun,
we're skipping off the concrete like firecrackers.
My guys quickly,
man,
the 57 record this rifle and got off a few rounds.
It did little immediately we started getting hit with mortar fire.
My radio was shot up and I tried to get the company on the land line,
but it was out to my mind was on my men.
I'd lost two in the opening barrage and I had lost track of the two men on the
south side of the bridge.
This attack didn't make sense too much fire power for a few stragglers.
So He's,
again looking back to the recon report that he got,
it looked like the 4th of July fireworks as tracers skipped off the concrete.
But I soon realized that some of the fire was coming from our left flank.
Jesus Christ.
It was our own company firing at us.
So we got a little blue on blue going down.
Which again for folks that are in the military,
blue on blue is a real thing.
And if you don't pay attention to and you don't plan for it can absolutely
happen to,
you know Lafe was saying that the other day.
If you would have asked him before we went on deployment,
what are the chances that you're involved in a blue on blue situation?
Before we went on deployment,
life would've been like no chance.
I would never happen to us.
And then during deployment,
you know there was,
there was the,
I think we talked about three blue on blue possibilities.
Well one real and in two possibilities in the extreme ownership.
And you know,
one is the opening story of blue on blue.
One is Lafe with Chris Kyle who's getting ready to take a shot and you know,
life is basically getting asked,
hey,
take that guy out.
And Lafe puts the brakes on it and it turns out being friendly.
US Army soldiers.
And then one where I got guys on the rooftop of a building and there's a a
Bradley fighting vehicle that's wanting to engage it with 25 millimeter chain
gun.
And they're looking,
they're reporting that they're looking at one building but they're actually look
and I'm and all indications are yes you can engage.
Those are enemies.
Snipers on that rooftop take 'em out.
But on the same block,
a few buildings down.
And it was actually considered,
was actually like probably a couple blocks away was my guys and that gunner in
that Bradley that was reporting it and he just got a little bit a little bit off
on which building was which building.
Oh yeah.
So he was actually pointing at one building and just thought he was.
So he,
he's looking through,
they've really good imagery on those buildings,
especially the thermo,
so you can see like white hot and he's looking at a building down this long
street and he's reporting,
I don't,
I forget what the buildings were,
but the building,
he's in your reporting building 50 I've got an enemy enemy personnel on the
rooftop and my guys were in building a hundred.
Yeah.
So he's asking,
does anyone have any true,
any friendly troops in building 50 no.
No one has any troops in building 50 oh,
there's a,
there's an enemy with,
with a sculpt weapons there.
And everyone's thinking,
Hey,
this is the sniper that's been killing our guys by the way.
Right.
Let's take 'em out.
And then looking at,
and what I actually told them to do,
I was like,
hey,
before,
and,
and the reason I was heads up was because we had blue on blue.
I knew that this was a possibility.
So I said,
count the buildings from your intersection up to the target building.
And so then it just went quiet for a little while and he comes back,
he's like,
standby,
because he caught himself,
you know,
gives,
you can see on the battle map,
it's like,
okay,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven and that's what he,
whenever he gets to 12 and he's like,
oh wait,
I'm in the wrong spot.
And you realized it.
It's,
it's like,
uh,
you know,
so it's still down.
But yeah,
you don't want to be on a rooftop getting hit with 50 or 25 millimeter chain gum
from a Bradley fighting vehicle is not going to be a good situation.
No,
sir.
At all.
And so the same thing's going on here.
You got firefight going on at night,
you got troops moving around and these guys are getting lit up by their own men,
all kinds of ways tactically to deconflict these things.
But you have to pay attention to you.
And one of the things you have to do is you have to have the humility to
recognize that it can actually happen.
Yeah.
Okay.
Back to the book,
the Koreans were all over the place.
Mack was hit worse than he thought.
I could feel his back.
It was drenched in blood.
He started to choke.
I talked to him but he didn't answer.
I laid him down and at the same time hollered to the rest of the men to pull in
tighter around the road.
I had four men left are two jeeps were shot up,
one was on fire.
I knew at this point we could not hold the bridge,
get the breach,
get the breach block from the 57 and throw it in the river.
A yelled to my guys.
So,
so that's sort of like,
that's like one of those when you make that call right there,
which is disable our weapon permanently cause we're going to not make it.
We don't want the enemy to be able to use this when may capture it in a matter
of minutes.
That's what he's saying is,
you know,
get the breach block out and throw it in the river.
Yeah.
And then of course the North Koreans attack again and got within 20 feet before
we stopped them.
I rushed to the other side of the road and got slammed to the ground from an
explosion confused.
I stumbled into a nearby ditch.
My head was ringing.
I checked Mac.
He was dead and so were the other two men on his side of the road with only two
men left.
We had to leave the bridge.
I shoved a grenade in the breach of the 57 the grenade exploded,
destroying the gun and we started pushing up the ditch away from the bridge.
I couldn't see or hear anything.
Okay.
We had not gone very far when the point man told me someone was coming down the
ditch toward us,
I took a knee and re readied my rifle.
Hold your fire until they get closer.
I whispered
the point,
man yelled quickly back.
Sarge,
their own guys to two of them from battalion.
Come over here.
What's going on?
I barked at them.
The men looked at crazed both.
We're talking a mile a minute and I tried to settle them down.
Look,
take it easy.
I told them slowly.
Tell me what you know.
The battalion got hit.
They were in the headquarters before we knew it.
The whole damn place was a mess.
One of the soldiers said there were dead and wounded all over.
Everything was shot up.
It looked like an artillery barrage made a direct hit.
It was total chaos.
Okay.
What are you to trying to do?
I asked.
They said they were trying to make contact with someone.
Sarge,
I'm Taylor,
one of Walsh's men,
the other guys from first battalion in the dark.
I didn't recognize him.
Where's Walsh?
They're all dead.
Sarge Taylor said,
okay,
so they make movement towards that battalion headquarters area and there's still
some friendlies there.
We stumbled into the battalion headquarters area at,
and I introduced myself and asked Jones what the situation was.
It was not good.
There were 30 or 40 wounded or dead doc Anderson and the chaplain and are in the
command post trying to take care of the wounded.
Jones thought the battalion commander was dead.
They just walked in on them and shot up the whole damn place.
So at this point they kind of Ziggy out of there into a tree line and we got
into the woodline and through ourselves to the ground completely exhausted.
And from there the chaplain moved onto another position,
but before he left,
he told me we were fighting the Chinese.
We'd heard rumors about the Chinese soldiers coming over the border.
That pretty much confirmed what I had fought for the last couple of hours.
Jones had basically told me when he mentioned that they're quilted,
uniform jackets looked much different than the North Koreans.
First Lieutenant Phil Peterson and Walt Mayo had also scrambled into our
perimeter.
Both officers were artillery forward observers,
but had lost their radios in the confusion.
They'd gotten reports hours before the attack that the Chinese were in the area.
The Chinese soldiers,
soldiers had crossed the Yay Lou to protect electrical generators along the
river that night.
Peterson had seen a Chinese prisoner in his quilted jacket,
but had no idea the danger we were in.
They'd been ordered back to the battalion and then tried to escape when
artillery unit tried to save their own Howard sirs.
But the Chinese had already cut the road.
We were trapped.
Yeah.
For the rest of the day we set up our defenses.
We knew the Chinese would come for us that night.
So that's it.
Right now they're,
they're surrounded and
yeah,
they set up a perimeter to the best of their ability and they got a bunch of
wounded.
They're low on ammunition.
They're low on food or low on water.
And so a perimeter is basically,
for those of you that don't know,
you set up 360 degree security perimeter.
You dig some Fox holes,
you put machine guns pointing out,
it's your,
it's your last stand situation.
Now it doesn't always last stand because when you're on a normal patrol,
you set up a perimeter.
Anytime you stop,
you set up 360 degree security.
Hmm.
And in this
situation,
that's what they're doing.
They're set up their perimeter to the best of their ability with what they've
got left.
And then there's a little command post in the center of the perimeter and here
we go back to the book,
inside the command post,
I knew what the officers were talking about.
It was a forbidden subject.
What were we,
what were we going to do with the wounded in the terrible final mo moment that
everyone knew was coming,
the battalion surgeon,
doc Anderson and the chaplain were doing what they could for about 40 wounded
men,
but we couldn't hold out for long without a relief column,
meaning people coming to back them up.
And if we had to run the wounded officers,
we're going to have to decide whether or not to leave themselves and the other
wounded men behind to the mercies of the enemy.
And once he kind of hears that inside the center of the perimeter,
during the,
at the,
at the command post there he goes back out to his edge of the perimeter.
And then here we go,
back to the book,
I saw a group of 20 men running right at us.
They were Americans and were hollering and waving at us.
I prayed there.
They were the lead element of a relief column because of course they're hearing
rumors that someone's going to come,
there's pee,
there's friendlies on the way.
That's what they're getting.
They're kind of,
and it,
I wasn't clear where they were getting those rumors from or whether they were
just assuming like,
hey,
we're here.
Americans are going to come to get us.
They've got to be sending in a relief battalion.
We just need to hang on.
So that's what he's saying.
I prayed that they were the lead element of a relief column.
The other guys were cheering them on as they made the short dash two our trench.
They slid inside their chest,
chest heaving.
What unit are you guys from?
I asked second of the eighth an officer said between deep breaths,
the stragglers pushed by us and collapsed in the center of the perimeter.
Everyone's morale sank lower than whale shit.
The energy and excitement seem to deflate from the men in the trench and all at
once.
Their heads Hoang and shoulders dipped.
These guys weren't a relief column.
They were just more stragglers from the second battalion.
I couldn't shake the thought
that no one was coming for us.
There's a soldier that he talks about,
a Polish guy,
I mean American guy,
but of Polish descent,
last names,
a Wallach.
Later that day,
I,
so now they're in their perimeter.
Later that day,
Wallach sent for me.
I walked across the west side of the perimeter and som standing near a machine
gun position.
He looked and started pointing out towards what looked like an open field.
Look over there.
He said,
I watched where he was pointing.
I didn't see anything.
I looked at him and shrugged my soldiers.
No,
keep looking.
He said,
this time staring intently.
Okay.
Then I saw it,
a faint shovel full of dirt flying right into the air.
The little bastards were digging a trench.
There were about a half does nor so digging a path right for us.
Our machine guns had been keeping them at a distance,
but when their trench was done,
they could move undercover right up to the edge of our trenches.
So that's a determined enemy.
They're just going to spend all day digging toward you as clandestine as they
can,
but they can only keep it so clandestine and no one the only,
only one soldier noticed
back to the book.
Sunset was a bad time.
Night always meant another attack.
It started with a probe.
A few Chinese soldiers would move up to the perimeter,
followed by a short and violent firefight.
Shortly after the probe,
the artillery and mortar fire would start followed by the demonic ball of brass
bugles and whistles.
As the Chinese infantry attacked
the,
now he's talking about his guys.
The men looked at me with weary and tired eyes.
All of us had scruffy beards and our skin was caked with mud and blood.
None of the soldiers could look at me,
okay?
They knew that they wouldn't survive unless they got up and fought,
but they just sat there,
okay?
They were not cowards,
just frozen by fear.
For some,
this was their first taste of combat.
Boys who overnight we're forced to become men.
I could only imagine the terror they must have been through.
Must have been going through.
You've got two choices.
I yelled,
okay,
get up and get to the line or I'll shoot you.
Okay.
That shocked them into action.
I don't think they fought.
I would shoot them.
I had no sooner finished prodding the men out of their interior holes than one
hell of a fight took place at the battalion command post.
I knew there were mostly wounded soldiers there and I feared for Jones,
the lone man on the machine gun,
but I had my own problems.
The bugles and whistles broke the silence and the Chinese rush.
The east side of our perimeter,
they came in waves straight into our fire.
As quickly as they fell more appeared,
they moved into our fire like they were possessed.
I raced from trench to trench moving men where the Chinese concentrated their
attack.
When their attack on the east side slowed,
they launched an attack on the west side.
Although we were dug in,
our casualties were mounting.
I kept moving men to wear the most.
Chinese were concentrated,
the attack slowed down,
but it was not long before they began an assault on the west side of the
perimeter.
Okay.
Now they get this idea as these attacks are taking place,
there's these trucks that were there,
kind of abandoned trucks and they figure it's nighttime.
If they can set these trucks on fire,
then it will allow them to see the enemy and so that's what they do.
They want,
once one of these attack starts,
they,
they shot the gas tanks and then shot tracers until all the vehicles were on
fire.
When the Chinese name for tree men ran past,
we could see them silhouetted against the light.
It was a shooting gallery.
We cut down the first wave only to watch the next one's climb over their
comrades and keep coming.
We mowed down the next wave,
but they still kept coming for the rest of the night.
The Chinese came up at us like waves to the shore,
but each time we stopped them,
they never reached the perimeter.
The next morning we took stock of our situation.
Water and food were a problem,
but ammunition and the wounded were our biggest concern.
We had 85 able bodied men left out of about 200 the rest were dead or wounded.
We were also out of morphine and the screams of the wounded,
we're starting to have an impact on the rest of the men.
Yeah,
I could see in their eyes a tired haggard look.
a relief.
Calm is calling for us.
They'll get through today.
I told the man as I walked the line,
I said it over and over again hoping to calm them and as I realized in
hindsight,
probably hoping to convince myself,
okay,
I hope to hell I was right.
Now
this is just a little report again about chaplain coupon and he gets a report.
Um,
Richardson gets a report and it says this,
the doc said that when the Chinese got into the Dugout,
chaplain coupon stopped them from killing all the wounded by surrendering
himself.
The Chinese took him and 15 of the walking wounded,
including my old company commander,
Captain Mccabe.
Okay.
What coupon did was heroic stopping the Chinese
when he left,
he was carrying Sergeant Miller.
So chaplain coupon.
This once again,
heroic actions saving the lives of these guys before they were slaughtered by
the Chinese,
by surrendering himself.
When I got back,
I organized about a dozen guys to follow me out of the perimeter and gather up
some of the Chinese weapons and ammunition.
We were out of almost everything but lying in front of us were weapons and
ammunition including much needed grenades.
Before we left,
I told the men to be careful because some of the Chinese might still be alive.
It was gruesome business,
but the only solution to our most pressing problem crawling over piles of dead
Chinese.
The smell was overpowering at time.
I could hear gas seep out of the decaying corpses.
I could hear men behind me gag and throw up.
Yeah,
so this is like a,
this is like you've got to sit around,
you got to,
you got to imagine what this is like that they are.
The Chinese attackers are literally stacked and piled on top of one another and
you're so low that you have to go out and gather weapons and ammunition from
them and as you're doing that,
they're bloated.
Bodies are giving off gases and it's the smells so horrible and the whole scene
is so horrific that your men are dry heaving and throwing up as you're trying to
do this.
Back to the book for the rest of the morning,
we passed out our new trove of ammunition and dug in deeper as we worked,
I heard the faint buzz of an airplane overhead.
The spotter plane that had dropped a bags of medical supplies was back.
So I skipped over this part,
but there was a,
they got some medical supplies from a little plane and this time instead of
dropping supplies,
it dropped the message and this time the pilot dropped it on target.
Guru grow opened the message from one of the one of the other guys grow.
I hope I'm pronouncing that right.
G I r.
O.
U x grow opened the message.
I saw the color leave his face.
I knew what the message said before he told me we were on our own.
No relief column was on its way.
Our new order was simple.
We needed to get back to friendly lines the best way we could
while grow.
Got the officer's together.
I gathered up a few of the sergeants and we had a meeting.
Well,
we are on our own.
That message told us to get back the best way we can.
I told the Sergeants Wallach was the first one to speak up.
We can't just leave the wounded.
What the hell else are we going to do?
A sergeant I didn't recognize,
said the meeting was tense.
I realized that what I had been telling them was going to happen wasn't going to
no relief,
no rescue,
and if we stayed in this hell hole,
we would all die.
I don't think we can keep the Chinese out of the perimeter for one,
for more than one more night if we can even do that.
I said
there was silence.
We were facing death,
but bravery is a funny thing that comes in all shapes and sizes and appears in
men.
You would least expect it from
most of us.
Didn't know one another,
but we fought hard together like we were blood brothers.
What do you say about staying one more night?
Maybe somehow they'll break through Louis tomorrow.
I said,
tomorrow we talk about the wounded
Wallach nodded his head and looked at the others,
um,
for staying one more night,
everyone quickly agreed.
No one wanted to leave the wounded.
I told grow the way the men felt and after he met with Bronzer,
Mayo and Peterson,
they all agreed.
No one was comfortable leaving our wounded or the wounded nearby in the
battalion headquarters,
the Chinese that night,
the Chinese attack three times and three times we held,
but not without suffering more casualties.
After the last attack,
I literally fell into a hole near the center of the perimeter.
I was fighting a losing battle against sleep.
I could feel myself slipping away.
My body felt numb,
damp and heavy.
Okay.
There was no noise,
no sound.
I was paralyzed and the harder I tried to move,
the more I felt,
the more my body felt like stone.
I tried to scream nothing.
I tried harder.
I couldn't make a sound
bugles and the distance cleared my hazy mind.
I could hear the Burp Burp of Chinese sub machine guns,
but the cop,
but not the constant rattle of our own machine gun closest to me.
I instantly got a sick feeling.
I bolted out of the trench and crawled toward the machine gun position and fell
into the whole head.
First the gunner was wounded and the assistant gunner was trying to put the gun
back into action.
There was Ammo,
but the gun was jammed.
I racked it back.
Nothing.
The headspace was screwed up.
The Chinese were the worthy.
The Chinese were within 20 yards of us and I was screaming for the men to keep
firing.
I pulled the gun into the hole and started to take it apart.
I adjusted the headspace,
put the barrel and chamber and alignment and reassembled it.
The Aa Garner,
the assistant gunner,
laid the ammo belt in and slap the cover down.
I rock the boat back and pulled the trigger.
The gun jumped back to life.
The fire immediately had an impact and drove a wedge into the advancing
soldiers.
The first book,
the first burst took out half a dozen.
Some of the wounded and dead Chinese fell into our trenches.
Others crumbled in a heap near the edge,
close enough that we could reach out and touch them.
I looked down and saw that the gunner was dead.
The aid gunner was hit in the arms and I could see blood staining is fatigue
jacket,
but he kept firing his rifle and replacing ammo belts when the machine gun went
dry.
Okay.
Just as fast as it started,
the attack ended.
There were some sporadic firing from the other side of the perimeter.
A couple of guys close to the gun position came over to me and took over.
As I headed back to my hole,
I crawled over several dead American and Chinese.
Yeah.
Every trench and whole seem to be filled with wounded men screaming and crying
for their mothers,
always their mothers.
We had an added problem now since some of the wounded war Chinese soldiers.
Yeah,
the dead.
We're not a problem.
We just pushed them out in front of the trench,
but the wounded we had to help if we could.
The medics did their best,
but we barely had enough for grown men.
Okay.
The Chinese were all scared to death,
crying and moaning.
They were the enemy,
but they were also soldiers just like us.
Okay.
And it was difficult to see them that way.
The next morning,
Brahms or in Guerrero called me over to them,
the two artillery lieutenants,
Mayo and Peterson.
We're also,
their Gross said what we all knew.
Yeah,
we can't stay here any longer.
There is no doubt in my mind that the Chinese will overrun us tonight.
He said,
we need to find a way out.
We'll leave.
Will you lead a patrol lieutenant?
Mayo and Peterson have already volunteered to go.
I looked at the lieutenants and nodded my head yes.
So they're going to try and find a way out of this perimeter and they're doing
to do a little reconnaissance tonight or or now to try and figure out their
route so that then later they can get out of there and come up with a plan to
get out of there,
back to the book as we grow.
And so they're crawling down a trench to try and look for the,
for the way out.
As we crawled down the trench toward the east side,
word got out that we were going on patrol.
Okay.
Peterson crawled by a badly wounded radio operator,
Lieutenant Peterson,
where are you going?
Looking for a way out.
He said,
Lieutenant Peterson,
the radio operator,
pleated,
please don't leave me here.
Please don't leave me.
You can't leave me here for them to get me.
Yeah.
Peterson looked shaken and I urged us forward.
I heard him say he was sorry.
As we crawled off.
Yeah,
others reached out to us,
patted us on the back
and wished us good luck.
Okay.
As we move down the river bed,
the Chinese soldiers
grabbed it us and held out cops begging for water.
I took my canteen and turned it upside down to show them that we had no water,
so there's the enemy.
They're also wounded laying in these trenches.
It's just a total blood bath and the Chinese soldiers are asking these Americans
and he couldn't even imagine what guys look like at this point.
They'd been fighting for weeks on end.
They have no water.
They've had no food.
They're out ammunition there covered in blood.
I mean Richardson's actually wounded
and his,
sorry state,
they're in.
You've got the Chinese soldiers that are even worse state begging for water.
Okay,
so these guys find a route and I don't wanna make it sound like they found some
easy escape route that's going to work.
They found a possible way of getting out of this perimeter.
And when they get back
they,
they come back and put out the word like,
okay,
this is what we're going to try and do and to grow talk.
And he says,
we move at 1700 before the Chinese move in.
Gross said word was passed to all able bodied men.
They were told to make sure that they took what ammunition they had left.
I got a burp gun and some ammo.
The wounded men knew what was happening.
Some broke down,
cried and begged us not to leave.
Please,
dear God,
take us.
One soldier begged me,
grabbing at my shirt.
Don't leave us to the Chinese.
Others just watched in silence.
They knew they'd slow us down.
They also knew that they'd be dead soon.
They simply asked that we come back for them,
but I knew we were leaving them to die or worse get captured.
I knew my orders and agreed with them,
but I couldn't shake the feeling that I was leaving.
So many good men,
men who'd fought well only to be left behind to die.
I wasn't sure I could ever forget this.
Miss was the hardest thing I had done in my short lifetime.
Okay,
this is your classic scenario of May.
What do we do?
We do.
We know we leave no man behind,
so then what's going to happen if they do that is everyone is going to die
and they make the decision.
Now,
we could have a theoretical debate on,
well,
maybe if they fought it out,
maybe if they stuck together,
maybe they could defeat the Chinese that are surrounding them.
In my estimation,
this is wrong and you can see these guys already stayed longer and they've
already done everything that they can.
They're out of ammunition there surrounded by Chinese.
The Chinese have unlimited number of men that are literally in piles around them
and they know that if they are going to,
if anyone is going to survive,
the need to make a break for it and again,
it's theoretical for us it,
it's sitting here,
it's hypothetical.
We could say all,
we'd stay in fight,
we could say whatever you want to say right now,
you're not in that position.
So now they leave at around five o'clock they start making a move.
A few hours into the march the rain turned into a downpour.
In minutes we were soaked to the skin,
the temperature was dropping and started and I started to shiver.
Moving was the only way to stay warm.
I pushed on trying to get as many miles as possible between us and the old
perimeter.
We were well behind Chinese lines and because of the size of our group it was
likely that we'd be spotted soon.
Now this is interesting trying to move with,
I think they said they had an 80 able bodied man.
Maybe it's 60 that's a massive number of people.
You can't hide 60 people.
It doesn't work.
You can,
well,
I shouldn't say you can't.
It's very,
very difficult to hide.
60 people like a platoon of 40 guys like it.
It's hard.
You know,
in the seal teams we have little tiny elements to little tiny platoons,
a 16 guys.
You can find some terrain that will,
that will hide you wheeze work in squads with eight guys.
Like,
okay,
we can,
we can find a place to hide.
When you have 60 or 80 guys behind enemy lines,
that's going to be a challenge.
I mean,
just think about where can you hide though that many people,
like a perfect terrain,
feature a ravine,
you know,
something like that.
That's a lot of people to put into a ravine and just the noise discipline of
people.
You know who,
who's gonna Cough,
you get 60 people,
someone's going to cough.
I mean just you and me sitting in this room and we noticed when one of us costs
because we're one to one of us grunts or whatever because we're recording it.
Yeah,
but you think about w you know,
you and I sitting here for two hours for three hours.
I would say five times during that one of us will cough.
Right?
And you got to go edit it out.
Sure.
So if that's happening with two of us,
you put 80 people into a ravine where they're trying to hide from the enemy and
there's how many people are coughing.
You know how many people are,
are sneezing,
right?
And it's not,
it's not good odds.
And that's where these guys are saying,
he is Richardson saying,
look,
we have a massive group and it's not going to be easy to,
uh,
to hide
back to the book.
We need to get moving to take advantage of the dark.
I left the house,
they'd been a little house.
Speaking of hiding,
I left the house frustrated sergeant mayor from the battalion's intelligence
section called me over.
Let's get outta here.
He said,
you and I have a better chance to get back to this group is too large.
We don't have the fire power to fight and they're slowing us down.
Okay,
sorry.
Here's a guy saying,
let bro.
Let's just make a run for it.
He was right.
I knew that we'd probably make it back to friendly lines together.
Breaking down into smaller groups would be better,
but I'd helped shepherd these men too far to turn my back on them.
Even if it costs me my life.
Sorry,
can't do it.
Mayor shrugged and disappeared into the darkness.
So exactly what I just said.
This guy made the decision.
You know what?
Now going alone,
that's not a good idea either.
You know,
cause now you've got no one to support you.
You've got no one to watch your six.
I mean that's just a bad idea.
You can't,
you're going to need to sleep at some point and you're by yourself.
What happens when you start snoring?
Right?
But this guy figured I've got a better chance of doing this by myself,
so I'm going to break out.
Now you could have given an order like,
hey everyone,
there's something called the escape and evasion when you're just,
everyone's basically every man for himself.
You could do that.
But at this point Richardson is like,
Hey,
we made it this far.
We're going to,
we're going to stick together.
Back to the book.
My group climb to the top of the knoll.
I could see the rounds hitting a mountain no more than five miles away.
We were close for the first time.
I felt hope.
Then the halo erupted with machine gun and mortar fire.
I was knocked flat on my face.
I quickly got up and just as quickly got back down in the prone position,
the Chinese were shelling the hill.
My lower back felt wet and I could feel what I thought was sweat running down
the crack of my ass.
It wasn't sweat.
They was blood.
I was hit,
but I didn't feel anything.
There was so much smoke,
dirt,
and dust that I could barely see.
I stumbled off the hill,
followed by three others.
There were about a dozen Chinese soldiers chasing us.
I prided myself to think and move.
We started to head for a village on the other side of the road behind the
village.
I could see a massive rice patty that ran up to a hill.
I figured we could escape it if we got over the hill first.
The Patty had about three or four inches of water in it.
We stayed on the tops of the dikes and got halfway across the patty before I
turned to fire back.
The Chinese soldiers dove for cover.
When they did,
we started running again.
As I was running,
I saw a rounds hitting the water in front of me.
It's not good.
When we got to the other side,
we got down behind the dike and started firing at the Chinese again.
I didn't see anyone behind them.
If we could take them out,
we had a chance,
but the others didn't have it.
Any ammunition left and I was down to a few rounds myself.
Get going.
I said,
I'll hold them off.
They looked at me for a second go.
I screamed and turn toward the Chinese soldiers.
Crossing the Patty.
I fired a few shots and then dove behind a dyke.
A few seconds later,
I fired two more bursts before I was out of ammunition
between burst,
my mind was searching for an escape route.
I knew that if I ran straight up the hill,
I didn't stand a chance about 30 yards to my right.
There was a house,
a woman and a baby were crying and wailing in a dug out near the hill.
I went into the house.
If I wanted into the house,
I was sure the woman would tell them,
but I couldn't stay behind the dike with no ammunition.
Jumping up,
I ran behind the house and started up the hill.
I tried to keep the house at my back hoping to mask my movement.
I went as far as I could go without the Chinese seeing me and then dove into a
large Bush rolling onto my stomach with my Chinese burp gun underneath me.
I waited.
I had no Ammo,
but I had a death grip on the weapon.
It was like my security blanket.
I could hear the Chinese soldiers climbing up the hill.
They were yelling at one another.
I was trying not to move,
not even breathe,
a fly hovered around my face,
landing on my nose and mouth.
I tried to keep my mind close to everything.
I closed my eyes as they passed and took my first breath.
As I heard,
they're yelling behind me in a few minutes.
I was sure they were gone,
but every unit has one,
a straggler that can't keep up.
The Chinese straggler was so slow.
Then when he got close to the Bush,
he saw me.
I never moved and just shut my eyes.
He started to Holler to drove his bayonet into my,
but I felt the TTIP hit the bone.
When I opened my eyes,
I saw boots all around me.
My mind went to the BURP gun.
If I rolled over holding it,
they'd shoot me for sure.
I shot my arms out along the ground and rolled over,
leaving the burp gun in the mud.
They reached down and jerked me up.
The barrel of the pistol looked like the business end of 105 millimeter
howitzer,
a Chinese officer with red piping down the side of his pants had the pistol
pressed between my eyes.
He was screaming at me and Chinese and pointing up the hill.
I was numb and couldn't speak.
I lifted my shoulders and let them drop.
I thought of this moment many times,
and I know that if he pulled the trigger,
I would never have known it.
That would've been the end.
Okay.
I'd been captured now when I had no idea what to do,
at least when I was on the run,
I knew where I was going.
Even fighting for my life was easier than giving up all control.
I was now at the mercy of the Chinese,
so there you go.
Captured
did fought until he's literally out of ammunition and
there's nothing else he could do.
Hmm.
Nothing else he can do
ends up.
They must have some other guys that got captured.
They muster them all together.
Now we're going back to the book.
There were about 10 Chinese guards.
They lined up us.
They lined up beside us and moved us down the road a couple hundred yards.
Suddenly the one in the lead started yelling in.
The whole column stopped.
Okay.
The graph,
the guards grabbed us and made us kneel down in front of a ditch.
I could hear one of the soldiers barking.
What sounded bike orders in Chinese.
My mind went on full alert.
Okay.
They were going to execute us.
I felt the guy next to me shaking and another started sobbing.
My God,
this is it.
This is one of those situations where you expect to see your life flash before
your eyes.
I was ready to relieve really of scenes from my childhood,
good times in Austria,
anything to take my mind from Korea and this ditch.
Okay.
It didn't happen to me.
Yeah.
I just closed my eyes
instead of shots.
I heard laughing.
They motioned for us to get up.
The guy next to me was so emotionally drained that he couldn't get up.
I tried to help him,
but my hands were tied behind my back.
Get up,
I yelled,
don't let them laugh at you.
Get up.
They get to like a little building and they'd been carrying captured rifles this
whole time so they get to a little building in back to the book.
The Chinese dropped the pile of rice on the ground and motioned for us to eat
it.
The prisoners rushed in and started fighting over the grains.
I staggered back from the melee and angrily watched.
We've been turned into animals.
After all we'd been through.
Why were,
why were the others not helping one another?
Yeah.
Instead,
they pushed and fought.
I refuse to join in.
We needed leadership and control more than ever,
and I was going to begin leading by example.
So
they go to,
they get some initial interrogation.
Of course you don't have that mock execution.
Horrible.
And then he moves into the next chapter,
which is called death march.
We started north up the road at a good clip.
The guards circled us like sharks,
sharks,
pushing stragglers with their rifles,
hitting and kicking.
Anyone who stopped,
many in the group,
we'll wounded.
One man had a massive chest wound.
It was covered by bloodstain bandages.
He wheezed as he shuffled down the road,
my shoulder was a little stiff and the shrapnel in my back was wet and sticky.
But I felt lucky.
It was nothing in comparison.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Next time you're thinking you have a rough day.
How about you're a prisoner of war on a death march and you've got a massive
chest wound.
So now one of these,
some of the Chinese guards could speak English,
and here we go.
Pick up the wounded.
He kept saying in like a broken record guard started pushing us back toward the
back of the formation on the ground.
We're about 20 soldiers on Jerry rigged litters made out of burlap bags attached
and stretched between Poles.
10 more soldiers stood around them,
pick up the wounded.
The officer barked again.
It took four of us to carry one litter.
I grabbed the closes litter and hoisted it up.
The soldier and the litter had a horribly mangled leg,
has calf muscle was long gone and his foot rested on the inner limp on the
litter,
limp and lifeless.
None of the wounded men had seen a doctor since being captured.
I heard someone say they'd been in trucks but were dumped on the road when the
trucks were needed elsewhere.
A whistle sounded and we started to shuffle toward the men.
None of us were strong enough to carry the stretchers very long.
My shoulders burned.
I tried to focus on each step left right,
left,
right whenever things got tough,
my mind wandered back to the guy with the sucking chest wound or I stole a
glance at the guy on the litter with a mangled leg.
I vowed to never quit,
but soon my body started to break down.
I tried to get another prisoner to relieve me,
but everyone I asked looked away or move to ahead.
Okay.
Most Hayden,
the dark trying to stay as far away from the stretchers as they could.
You son of a bitch.
I barked at one soldier who almost jerked away when I asked.
I was disgusted.
It reminded me of the soldiers that first night fighting over the rice.
We'd forgotten that the backbone of any military was the bond of the soldiers.
We fought for the guys to our left and right.
That is why we fought to protect our unit buddies and we expected them to do the
same.
Put on a death march.
Every man was an island.
There seemed to be no place for anything else.
I refuse to be that way.
It's heavy burden.
Each night.
The guards were getting tougher.
They were constantly pushing and hitting men with the rifles.
If a man fell behind,
he was shot and pushed off the mountain side.
Everyone was rapidly losing weight,
lack of food,
wounds and dysentery.
We're taking their toll.
Carrying the men on stretchers was becoming even more difficult.
We looked like skeletons are uniforms hung off us like a scarecrows quote coat.
Each time we got topped,
each time we topped one of the mountains,
we faced another one.
Ears,
nose,
fingers,
and toes were becoming numb.
At times I felt like I was walking on my ankles.
I was lucky that my legs had always been the strongest part of my body.
Many of the wounded men who were strong enough to walk earlier,
we're now in the need of stretchers.
However,
there were none and we found ourselves carrying them along between two of us.
In some cases,
we are practically dragging them.
When I heard a single rifle shot back down the road,
yeah,
yeah.
I knew another man's struggle was over.
Okay.
My heart was aching for them,
but at the same time,
my mind kept telling me to move.
We had two choices,
March or die.
My survival mode kicked in,
not allowing me to surrender to pain and fatigue.
Okay.
The guards shoved us into a cluster of hot,
so after walking long time they get to dig into like a little village.
We were jammed into the room so tightly that my legs rested on another soldier.
The only thing good about sleeping this way was that we will warm or
a cold front from the plains of Manchuria came roaring down and slamming into
the very mountains we were struggling through.
We were facing the coldest winter in 50 years.
As we got ready to move out,
the commander of the guards told us to leave the stretchers.
The wounded were pleading with us to take them.
I started to move toward one and got a rifle button.
The Gut.
Others tried to grab the stretchers,
but the guards pushed them away too.
I started to move toward the helpless soldiers again,
but couldn't risk another blow.
I let my mind drift into a Zombie state hoping to block out the screams of the
wounded,
left foot,
right foot,
right foot
over and over again.
I repeated it until I couldn't hear their screams.
Cool.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Just absolutely horrible.
After 10 nights,
we marched into a fairly good sized town
and this is when he decides that he's going to try and escape pretty early on
and he's got a couple buddies and there's some confusion and there's some chaos
that that happens as they're trying to round up the prisoners and he kind of
jumps over with a couple of the guys into a little ditch and they cover up with
some branches
and they start talking to these three guys,
start saying,
look what you know.
Can we make a move?
Well,
let's,
you know,
let's head south and then finally one of the guys says,
that would be suicide in our condition.
We won't make it over those mountains.
We don't have warm clothes and we will probably die of hypothermia.
We knew he was right.
It was smarter to wait until springtime.
We needed to try and survive and hope our forces liberated us.
Now they're starting to get into like all the little bit of a routine.
My goal is to bring back discipline and start acting like soldiers again.
The scene,
the first night with the rice dropped on the ground was burned into my brain.
The only way we could survive until spring was an a possible escape attempt was
to start working together.
The sick and wounded suffered the most are frostbitten feet.
It turned to trench foot and open wounds were infected or gang green and said
in,
for those guys,
it was only a matter of time before they died,
since we had no medicine to treat them,
and finally from his little group,
he loses a guy whose last name is graves.
Graves was the first to die.
The valley had turned into one of death and suffering.
Soon after graves death,
chaplain coupon came to the house.
We were all surprised to see him.
I had last seen him at [inaudible],
but when he walked in,
I barely recognized him.
The man I'd met on a region Pusan was gone.
He'd lost a lot of weight and his uniform kind of hung on.
His frame is tired and worn out eyes.
Belied his warm smile
coupon told us who was dead or wounded before he left.
He told us to get organized.
We'll need to take action when the troops show up.
He said,
have a plan.
When the troops get close,
the North Koreans might try to kill us all
upon.
Never came back to my house,
but he continued to visit troops in the valley.
I know he prayed for each one of us when he could brought food to the starving
until he became so weak that the guards took him to the hospital.
Then we're going to hear about what that hospital consisted of.
He died of pneumonia in May of 1951 it was buried in a mass grave by the Yalu
River.
Okay,
and if you don't know the story about chaplain coupon,
he was awarded the Medal of honor for his actions in the Korean War.
And I'm sure we'll cover that in more detail at some point on this podcast,
but in the meantime you can look it up and read about a hero of war and a hero
of faith.
At one point,
Richardson tries to steal some Kimchi,
and again,
now I'm fast forwarding a bit to where
to where they're a little bit more settled in and he,
he steals like a bowl of Kimchi and they started,
the guards go all nuts and they're trying to find out who took the Kimchi,
who took the Kimchi and they,
they threatened them with a no one's going to be able to eat until we know who
took the Kimchi.
And finally he breaks down and says,
I did it.
Only me.
Now was the officer's turn to shake his head.
You lie more,
do it.
No,
only me and the guards.
I said,
the little son of a bitch looked at me and then nodded to the guards who grabbed
me and tied my arms behind my back.
You learn lesson.
Now the officer said the guards threw a rope over an open trust and pulled me up
by my arms until my feet barely touch the dirt floor.
The pain was excruciating.
I could feel lightening jolts of pain in my left arm and shoulder where I still
had shrapnel wounds.
The pain quickly crept up my arms driving straight to the top of my head.
I gasp for air.
The pressure on my chest allowed me to take only sharp short breaths.
I could hear myself moaning and once I cried out in pain before I passed out,
I woke up on the dirt floor.
I could barely feel the guards pulling the ropes off my arms.
I could hear the son of a bitch rattle off a few a few orders.
He sounded far away,
but I could see his boots and knew he was standing over me.
The guards dragged me to my feet throwing open the door.
They tossed me on the floor of my room.
I could barely move my legs and arms and stayed where I landed rest of the
night.
Martin helped me get comfortable and told me that the house had been fed earlier
that night.
He had no idea how long I'd been strung up.
The next morning I sat up and started making jokes.
Some of them laughed with me.
Others were just scared,
laughing,
hurt my ribs.
But it was the first time I've done it.
Since you saw him,
I was determined to keep my sense of humor.
I was tied.
It was tied to my will to live.
Okay.
From that point on,
I remember to laugh whenever I could.
Well,
I guess we won't be having Kim.
She anymore
after two months in the valley of the guards,
marches out of the valley and backup to the road in Pew tone.
So they're in a different location now
and in this location the Chinese have finally full,
fully take over the operation of the camp as opposed to the Koreans,
the North Koreans.
So now the,
it seems like the Chinese were a little bit nicer to the prisoners.
The Chinese issued each of us a small drinking cup along with a bowl for our
millet or our maze.
No more eating out of a helmet liner.
We were also allowed to start a Cooke house for each company.
We were occasionally given soybeans.
The wells were contaminated from animal and human feces seeping through the
ground and into the water.
Well,
so we didn't have fresh water.
There were about 3000 men in the camp.
Conditions were about as bad as a human being could possibly live with.
So again,
I pointed out that the Chinese were a little bit nicer because they gave him
like a bowl,
but it's,
don't get me wrong.
This was about as close as you could get to Andersonville and the civil war,
which that was a,
uh,
a confederate prisoner of war camp for union soldiers.
And there was about 45,000 soldiers that were captured in,
that were in that prison camp.
We're about 13,000 of them died from scurvy and from,
from diarrhea and dysentery.
So,
you know,
it's funny,
we think of like diarrhea,
first of all,
we think of as like a joke and then we think of it as like an inconvenience.
But when you're in these situations,
it kills you.
Hmm.
Back to the book.
We were full of lice.
The farm boys told us we were hot.
They were hog lice growing larger every day on our blood.
While the lice got fat,
we starved.
The guards brought us two bowls of millet a day and one bowl of boiled water,
which barely kept us alive.
And even when we ate disinterested,
kept weak and dehydrated hunger can do some strange,
strange things to your mind.
I was at the latrine,
a slit trench,
and I noticed that many of the soy beans,
we're past hole.
I thought if I picked them out of the feces and wash them off,
I could eat them.
Okay.
Then it dawned on me that I must be going crazy or turning it into an animal.
It would be a few days before I was able to get over the fact that I had let
myself sink to a disgusting fought like that.
So
next time you feeling hungry,
you're not feeling hungry.
You even know what that feels like.
Yeah.
They ended up,
uh,
like forming a little group.
And you just mentioned this,
this one guy in this group named Vincent Doyle Doyle became the leader of this
little group and infantry men during World War II.
You had a wife and a son in fall river,
river,
Massachusetts.
He received a battlefield commission in France and left the army as a
lieutenant.
He opened up a frozen food store in fall river.
A little ahead of its time.
Not many families had freezers.
He went out of business and reenlisted as a master sergeant,
not an officer.
He was an inch too short to be an officer of the army.
Told him.
Yeah.
That's one of the reasons why I left that in.
There was like the guys just humble like,
oh,
I can't cut it as an officer anymore.
Even though I got a battlefield commission in World War Two.
Oh,
that's okay.
I'll just,
I'll just enlist.
That's no for no factor.
That's,
that's like the humility.
I don't know if you see that kind of humility anymore.
Normally I don't make a big deal out of the generational differences,
but that's a pretty humble guy right there.
Yeah.
Back to the book.
Our biggest problem was our physical condition brought on by the march men with
open wounds.
Many with gang green didn't survive long.
Some were saved from gangrene by maggots eating their dead flesh,
which only meant they suffered longer.
I mean,
we've been through that before with a forgotten island or who they would
actually put magnets to get rid of dead flesh to try and save themselves.
Some of the soldiers had black feet from frostbite and trench foot.
I watched while one man pulled rotted flesh off his toe bones.
Yeah.
The soldiers from the Second Infantry Division had it worst they'd been issued
shoe packs,
rubber boots with felt liners and insoles.
Their feet would sweat and they were continuously wet while marching and they
would freeze when they stopped marching.
Since they never took off the shoe packs,
the soldiers got trench foot.
It's easily understood when men die of wounds or pneumonia.
It is more difficult to understand when men just lie down and quit.
Okay.
I've seen strong men seemingly just give up and die.
First they would stop eating and stare with blank eyes at the mud walls of the
hut.
Yeah.
Their minds were gone and life just slipped away.
Then after a few days,
you are at an all too familiar death rattle.
We were dying at a rate of about 30 a day.
Each morning we took out the dead,
stripped them of their clothes and stack them like cordwood in a pile.
At first we tried to take the uniforms and coats and give them to other
prisoners,
but the Chinese guards wouldn't allow it.
What they did with the uniforms is still a mystery.
Okay.
I hated being part of the burial detail.
The physical part was bad enough,
but the mental part was much worse.
Thoughts about the families of the dead men and if they left children behind who
might never know what happened to them.
I knew from listening to men talk that what bothered most of them was the
thought that they might be next.
That's one thing I never let my mind to think about.
Yeah.
And again,
he moves around a bit to various places and various camps and gets various jobs.
you have to read this book to really comprehend this.
The level of suffering that was endured by these prisoners back to the book in
early spring,
1951 the Chinese were building small docs on the river and I was unlucky enough
to be put to work on the crew.
A group of us were carrying one of these timbers up a hill.
When someone in the center stumbled,
stumbled,
and the timber fell pinning me to the ground.
Okay.
And when that happens is back,
gets jammed up and,
and even though he makes it through that day,
it starts getting worse and worse throughout the day.
Now,
okay,
there's a hospital,
right?
It's a hospital,
but they actually called this the hospital.
It's just like every other prisoner camp that we've heard about.
When you go to the hospital,
you're dead.
That's just a place they put you a diet.
It's the same thing here.
So his guys are trying to prevent him from being taken to the hall,
to the hospital.
So they're carrying him back and forth to their formations and finally the
Chinese realize that he can't walk.
So the Chinese come to the door and back to the book,
they were taking me to the hospital.
We called it the morgue.
We had never seen anyone return from there.
I wanted to fight back,
but I couldn't.
The guards close the door to one of the rooms in the cluster of houses that
served as the hospital and threw me in.
It was dark and I could not see anyone.
I landed on top of a wounded and sick lying on the dirt floor.
They immediately started kicking in,
cursing me.
The stench from the wounds and the human feces was unimaginable.
I started to gag.
So this is,
I mean,
this is just the,
I don't even,
I can't even imagine anything is going to be worse than the situation he's in
now.
These put in this giant room filled with shit and wounded people that are going
to die,
and by the way,
it's like they've got dysentery and they've got diarrhea.
So it's just a total nightmare and he's trying to maintain a little bit of
dignity and he asks one of the guys in the room,
where's the,
where's the latrine?
He had to use the restroom and the guy tells him out the door,
go left to the end of the building,
left again in 25 yards on a no,
you'll find the latrine.
The temperature was freezing,
but I welcome the fresh air.
I dragged myself out on my buttocks pushing myself along with my hands.
I reached the latrine,
a trench,
a foot and a half wide and 10 feet long.
The trench sat just outside.
A strand of wire that separated our camp from the black prisoners.
The human waste was like putting an,
almost reached to the top of the trench.
I managed to get my pants down and had worked my way to the edge when the side
caved in.
Okay?
I fell into the trench,
finally catching my shoulders on the edge.
The waste was at my chin.
As I clawed at the dirt,
trying to pull myself free,
my legs paralyzed like an anchor,
pulled me toward the bottom.
I yelled out and kept crawling,
climbing,
but every second I slipped deeper and deeper into the trench to black prisoners
on the other side.
Heard me.
They crawled through the barbed wire,
grabbed me by my arms and pulled me out a second later and I would have slipped
under the surface.
Yeah,
the guards heard all the commotion and we're closing in.
My saviors scrambled back through the fence.
Just as the guards arrived.
To this day,
I have no idea who saved me fearing I was trying to escape.
They started to beat me with the rifle butts.
I covered my head to try and protect myself.
As I lay there covered in shit.
I lost control of my bowels.
That was it.
Okay.
I was done,
but giving up meant def.
Okay.
I had lived with death every day since coming to Korea.
The battlefield was like a movie.
In fast forward,
there was so much going on and I couldn't dwell on death.
Very long call for the medic,
possibly hold the wounded man in my arms or say a word or two.
As he passed from life to death,
it was different.
As a prisoner.
I had no way of defending myself other than using my mind and what physical
capabilities I could muster.
I realized my mind had to be my strength
for a split second,
all of the pain and suffering could have ended.
No.
My mind screamed.
I could not give up.
I'd come this far and in that second I set my mind to doing something no one had
done.
I was going to come back from the morgue.
As the Chinese soldiers landed blow after blow on my back and legs.
I banished death from my mind.
Never again
did it enter into it.
Many lost control of their minds and did things they would never have done under
normal circumstances.
I didn't know what to say.
When I heard stories or saw things were men were mistreating one another.
I thought of the first night of captivity when the Chinese dumped the rice on
the ground.
What happens to men when they become prisoners?
Why did they change from helping one another and becoming and become totally
engrossed in themselves with totally selfish outlook on life?
I understand.
I'm not talking about all men,
but many never come to grips with losing their freedom.
They feel abandoned by their country and are no longer longer with men.
They trust in their minds,
their personal survival becomes paramount and group survival no longer matters.
So again,
I mean going back to that part at the latrine,
that's a little,
that's a little footnote you can put in your brain for the rest of your life
because we're all going to have bad situations.
I get it.
I mean,
there's going to be horrible things that are going to happen.
I don't know if there's much,
I don't know if it can get much worse than the situation that he was in right
there.
And,
and realizing
that his mind was his strength,
realizing that,
okay,
he had no other way to defend,
but he's mind had to be strong and he had that little split second thought that
he could give up and just let it all go.
Just let it all go.
Let that pain and suffering stop.
Yeah.
But then he realized,
no,
not going to do that.
Not going to surrender.
Not Happening.
Okay.
Yeah.
So eventually,
I mean he goes through more hell and eventually gets on two crutches and then
one crutch and eventually he makes it,
he makes it out of the morgue and he gets sent back with the rest of the rest of
the team.
And when he gets back,
they're like completely amazed that this is a guy that they,
they probably mourn his death cause they thought when you go to the morgue,
you're dead.
And when he gets back,
he's with Doyle and smoke.
These are his boys,
Doyle and smoke.
S.
M.
O a.
K.
Welcome back.
Doyle said,
says no one had ever come back from the morgue.
The guy's peppered me with questions about his treatment,
what treatment?
I said,
and they all laughed.
I told them we never received any medicine,
God,
less food.
And the room smelled like a cesspool.
I told them how I'd almost drown in the trench and that two guys from the black
compound saved my life.
It was a shitty situation.
I said,
and again,
they all laughed.
So this guy does a great job of trying to keep,
keep track of that humor
continuing since I'd been in the morgue,
the Chinese had started putting a lot of pressure on us.
We were required to spend hours in lectures and discussion groups supervised by
Chinese political officers.
This is when their indoctrination has taken place.
Doyle explained that the political officers began by breaking you down
physically,
so you started to agree with them and then just just to get them off your back
when this happened,
they would be on you full first portion you to make a statement against the
United States government or to make a statement as to the next wonderful
treatment that you're receiving.
Next,
you'd be one of the turncoats standing up on stage giving a lecture,
so they're going through this.
Even though they're getting,
trying to get propaganda statements out of them,
they're still getting treated horribly.
We were still dying in great numbers.
It had just been removed from our site.
They also tried to improve our diet.
Prisoners even started to make steam bred by taking balls of Dylan,
placing them on a bamboo rack.
Over a pot of steaming water.
And one of the,
one of the leaders I just had to note this one,
uh,
one of the interrogation propaganda communist leader said,
I will leave a hundred men to die to save one progressive
meaning communist
and they spoke English.
Those are the words that they used a Chinese interrogators propaganda.
People spoke English and he says,
we outwardly challenged the loss of individual freedom under their system.
The Chinese became quite agitated
and I liked this part.
So there again,
I mean,
I don't want to say that they're getting the treatments good by any stretch,
but it's at least a little bit better.
And it's part of it is them trying to convince them to,
you know,
be communists.
They can make statements against American,
do that whole thing.
So they,
here's the,
here's this one part.
Despite working many hours building the long houses,
we were still required to attend lectures.
And one,
a Chinese acting troupe came to town.
It was their version of a USO show called the white haired girl.
The storyline was simple.
A peasant family could not pay the taxes demanded by the dastardly landowner.
So he takes the peasants,
beautiful young black hair daughter as his concubine.
She suffers terribly under his demented date demands,
but eventually escapes to the mountains.
Years later,
as the People's Liberation Liberation Army frees the people,
the girl returns to the village,
but now her hair has turned completely white.
The play was well done and the Chinese officers and soldiers hung on every word.
They saw the girl story as their own.
They clapped when the People's Liberation Army arrived.
The play of course omitted the fact that Mao and killed thousands,
and I'll correct him there millions of people and his drive to take control of
China.
And this is why I read this part cause he says,
we laughed and cheered when the landlord drag the young girl away.
The Chinese guards were not amused and for days there was an awkward silence,
kind of got a kick out of that bunch of rambunctious prisoners of war ruining
your little play.
When it got warm enough,
the Chinese let us stay out of baseball field near the river.
We didn't have any balls or bats,
but we went through the motions.
We made teams and selected umpires.
We called balls and strikes.
It sounded weird,
but we had a lot of fun.
We spend hours out there and then he goes on to tell this story.
Late one afternoon I cry when I read that.
I was like,
that's kind of interesting.
I mean,
I could see where you'd do something to entertain yourself,
but they had a little bit of a bigger plan.
Late one afternoon alone,
American fighter jet came screaming down the river.
We were out on the ball field.
At first.
It scared the hell out of us.
It went by us in a flash,
but doubled back and flew straight down the river.
We could see the pilot looking down and as he passed the pilot waves and wiggled
his wings at us,
there were no words to describe how that incident made us feel.
God bless him.
He probably never knew.
That's what that simple act did for us.
It was very long time before we stopped talking about it and we'd achieved our
goal with the ball field.
The Chinese refuse to identify POW camps,
but the ball field did the trick,
uh,
soon after when winter set in,
so now they're going to another winter.
I got sick,
started running a high fever and was coughing up green and yellow mucus.
Doyle and smoke moved me near the stove and kept me hydrated with hot water.
A medic told me I had pneumonia.
I thought of graves and was grateful that I wasn't still in the morgue.
After a couple of days,
the fee,
the fever broke and I got better Doyle and smoke both.
They were sure I'd make it.
Yeah.
Rich.
Some of us thought we might need to dip you in the Shit House again to make you
better as what?
Smoked all the time.
Okay.
In early spring,
my legs were finally in shape to begin thinking about escape again too.
When I read that,
I just wrote the words long game next to her.
I mean,
Bro,
can you imagine you're three years deep in prison camp and the whole time you're
thinking,
well,
if I can just take the next year to get my legs healed up enough where I can
walk,
then I can try and escape again.
Even when he first got capture is like,
okay,
if I can just make the springtime,
we'll be a little bit stronger to let the weather to talk about playing the long
game.
Yes.
They as they were planned in this escape,
uh,
they were going to take Doyle and smoke and they were talking about it and soon
smoke was doubled over.
Doyle tried to get the Chinese to do something,
but they ignored us.
Please soon smoke couldn't talk.
He just laid in bed and Moan.
When it got really bad,
he screamed.
Finally he passed out.
His face was locked into torment,
tortured,
grimace,
and his skin turned ashen at noon.
The medic that was helping him turn to us and shook his head.
Okay,
he's dead.
Yeah.
The words landed on us like mortar rounds.
I just stood there staring at his face and shock dead.
How could this have happened in such a short time?
Only seven months ago,
men were dying all around us.
It was normal since we'd moved,
prisoners didn't die anymore.
We were the survivors.
This wasn't supposed to happen to anyone anymore.
Okay.
The shock quickly boiled up into a rage.
And these guys kind of,
you know,
kind of yell at the Chinese and make a little,
they,
they kind of cause some,
some problems.
Um,
nothing too drastic,
but you know,
they weren't,
they weren't just cowering anymore.
Hmm.
Back to book.
The winter of 1952 to 53 was livable compared to the past two winters.
We were allowed to select our own leaders in organized committees to work on
different facets of our daily life.
Uh,
sanitation committee,
Athletic Committee.
A day we action committee all brought some semblance of order to our lives.
Food had improved too.
We got steamed bread,
vegetables and rice once in a while,
some fish and meat.
But it was usually just a scrap.
The change in Diet was enough to let us gain some weight.
July 27th,
1953 the Chinese had us all in a formation when they announced that a peace
agreement had been reached.
We stood silently looking at one another.
No one said anything.
This news had been a long time coming.
I just stood there,
a smile plastered across my face.
I looked down at my rail thin frame,
like a map.
It showed my journey,
scars on my back from shrapnel,
a missing tooth,
night blindness from lack of vitamins,
which luckily only lasted for a couple of weeks.
Okay.
I was one of the fortunate ones.
I'd survived
and that's it.
I mean,
that's like,
like it just changes immediately now.
They still have to get out of there.
To this day,
when I think of our movement south,
I still get butterflies in my stomach.
Okay.
They were moving us to the railhead at Ma'am Poe.
The Chinese gave one of the prisoners a lock and told them to close the gates
after the trucks pulled out.
After we passed,
he snapped the lock shot closing some of the darkest chapters in my life.
And um,
they continue this trains,
planes and automobiles to try and get to freedom.
We boarded and finally we get to,
we boarded the trucks and proceeded across the Freedom Bridge to freedom
village.
When we arrived,
I didn't wait for the tailgate to drop.
I jumped right out onto the ground.
There were two American escorts for each of us.
They grabbed me and I thought,
Holy Shit.
These guys were big and muscular.
I quickly realized they were average guys.
I was just a little skinny and at one point he gets on a scale.
He weighed 108 pounds.
Cool.
Our first stop was tent city in a thousand yard neutral circle in the rice
patties we stripped show.
We stripped,
showered and deloused having put on slippers and pajamas.
We were checked by good looking nurses.
We stayed less than an hour before we moving to another building to get uniforms
and our first meal after our meal,
we were formed by helicopter to a replacement depot in,
in Sean.
It was my first helicopter flight and I sat near the door and watched Korea pass
and a blurb below me.
I felt like screaming,
singing and dancing,
but instead I remain subdued,
quiet and happy.
Inside 57 years had passed and I can still remember how great it felt like being
born again
and he gets on the phone and he says,
I reached my dad.
I could hear the excitement in his voice.
He bombarded me with questions.
Are you all right when you coming home?
Don't worry about me.
I'll be okay.
Okay.
There was some kind of calmness inside of me that was difficult to describe.
I'd been through so much that just being free and headed home was enough.
After worrying about Living Day in and day out,
I wondered if anything would ever bother me in the future.
The voyage back to California on the Brewster,
which was the ship they were on was great.
They serve three meals a day.
The small things mattered more now than before.
We were subjected to daily debriefings,
which were more like interrogations by intelligence officers.
He goes through answering a bunch of questions about what he saw and what he
went through when they were actually trying to figure out if there were more
like how many other prisoners war.
There are other prisoners that were left behind.
He finishes those and those interrogations are those questioning or Intel
gathering situations and then for the rest of the voyage,
I stayed on the deck.
I sucked in the fresh sea air and bashed in the warm breeze.
Everything I could hear,
smell and see was so full of life.
As I looked over the rail of the ship,
I remembered three years ago looking down at the sea and praying that I would
have the strength to lead my men in combat.
Yeah.
Now I was returning by myself.
I had been born again,
a chance to live for tomorrow to make the most of every day and never look back.
I had survived the greatest laboratory of human behavior,
one that no education could ever equal.
Weeks later,
the Golden Gate Bridge jutted out of the fog as the ship pulled into port.
We had a few hours before our flight,
so I left and walked around the post.
My path took me to the post cemetery.
It was very quiet and my thoughts were on all of the men and friends that will
no longer with me.
Walsh grow smoke.
I could feel them standing above me.
I hope they were smiling and happy for me because it was my men,
my section that had kept me motivated and alive.
I owed my freedom and survival to them.
A number of us flew to Chicago where we changed planes.
When the plane left Chicago,
I was the only returning prisoner of war board.
Although the plane was full of people,
I felt very lonely.
I was free and on my way home with mixed emotions,
I realized that I had just left men that I had lived with 24 hours a day for 34
months.
They were sad that with all the freedom surrounding me,
that there was an empty feeling.
There were also false of the ones who would never return.
The ones whose lives had been lost almost before they began.
When we landed in Philadelphia,
the stewardess asked if we would remain seated for just a minute while a special
passenger exited the plane.
Am I surprised that special passenger was me?
I walked down the stairs and onto the tarmac
waiting there where my mother and father,
they hugged and kissed me.
This time,
unlike on the street before the war,
I realized the act of affection between father and son was a wonderful thing and
I will never forget the emotion on my father's face.
As tears welled up in his eyes
and he goes on and there was a whole story within a story within a story in this
about a woman that wasn't an associate,
a friend and and,
and several others.
And there was,
there's a whole other realm to this,
but
he gets,
you know,
he starts to get back on with his life a little bit back to the book.
While I was absorbing the sounds and sights of freedom,
I was beginning to think about my future.
I had been given a second chance and was determined that I was not going to blow
it.
Claire and I had become inseparable.
And I was falling in love with her.
My only fear was that the feeling might not be mutual.
We had a wonderful Christmas holiday in both realized that we were definitely
meant to be together during the New Year's Eve party.
I gave clear and engagement ring.
She said yes.
We announced to everyone that we were going to be married.
There were happy people,
sad people and mad people to tell the story behind this statement would take
another book.
But five children and 56 years later we're still happily married.
Yeah.
And from there,
and this is,
this is like as I was researching this whole situation,
this is so he gets done with us and he ends up going to officer candidate school
in the army,
uh,
gets assigned to the 505th airborne infantry regiment.
That's fine.
Awesome.
Just outstanding.
And then he,
then he goes to special forces at Fort Bragg,
North Carolina.
And so he's,
you know,
becomes a green baret special forces guy.
And then he goes to Vietnam
and he is the two time commander of Project Delta in Vietnam,
which is like the,
the deep reconnaissance.
Like the,
the,
the uh,
the format.
Like this is how we do deep reconnaissance is based on project Delta and
product.
Delta was also had Beckwith and at Charlie Beckwith who is the,
the founder of Delta Force.
So,
you know,
Richardson just drives on and those deployments to Vietnam going into enemy
territory,
territory in enemy territory and ends up doing 39 years in the army
and,
and you know,
like you said,
has,
uh,
you know,
the wife and the kids and be incredible career in and after that,
has a civilian career,
he's still alive by the way.
Yeah.
Then here's what he closes out with.
He says,
every day on this journey,
I believed the men of the weapons platoon and my close buddies in prison.
We're watching me to see how I looked after my men and prepared them for
whatever they may have had to face.
I tried my best to make them proud of me.
So,
well I think that Colonel Richardson,
I think we can absolutely answer in the affirmative that yes,
I think anyone would be proud of how you handled yourself,
how you lead,
and then on top of that,
how you lived your life.
I mean,
I think that's just,
um,
self evident in every page of this book,
which once again,
valleys of death is unbelievable.
Book should be handed out to people.
It should be issued in the military as far as I'm concerned.
And I mean,
I think in reading the book,
I mean it's like your actions,
colonel,
Colonel Richardson,
his actions,
his behavior.
I mean,
how can you not be,
how can you not think to yourself that you can do a little bit better with the
situation that you're in
and realize how much people are,
how much human beings are capable of.
I don't,
I just don't,
I don't see how you could read this and not walk away and say,
you know what?
I'm going to do better.
And whatever situation you're in,
look,
and I know people who end up in horrible situations,
but no matter what that situation is,
no matter what it is,
you can,
you can move forward.
Yeah,
you can move forward,
you can keep your mind positive,
you can use your mind as your weapon
and also you can,
you know,
one of the parts in that's encompassed in that is like,
oh,
you can actually have,
have fun and keep your sense of humor when you're going through these terrible
situations,
which people ask me that all the time.
Like,
don't you,
do you think it's important to have a sense of humor of like,
of course I do.
You know,
But again,
um,
Colonel Richardson,
if you ever hear this,
obviously there is a wide open invite for you to come and debrief us and teach
us life lessons here and tell us about,
tell us more detail and the parts that I know I missed and things that I messed
up.
I apologize.
But,
uh,
thanks.
Thanks for your service.
Thanks for your sacrifice and thanks for showing us,
showing us
how to live properly,
even in the most dire of circumstances
with that.
That was low.
Yeah.
I was reading this book and it was just,
I couldn't,
I couldn't stop.
It's one of those books you just don't,
you just don't see it's,
it's,
it's so hard to understand like some of that combat the beginning is crazy.
It's crazy.
Just the situation that they were in.
I mean,
you're surrounded by the Chinese for three days and they're just a hammering
your perimeter on night with waves,
cumin waves,
and then you get the note dropped from a,
from a damn plane that says,
no relief is coming.
Find your way out.
Appreciate it.
Yeah,
and then you got to leave your wounded.
That's,
that's what happens.
It's like,
okay,
we either all die,
we're going to leave.
These are,
this is just like,
it's incredible.
It's incredible and you should read this or you get some sort of semblance of
maybe what your thoughts are going to be when you,
if you get into a situation like that,
whatever it is.
So yeah,
always learning.
Always.
And for me again,
I get done with this and I can't even sleep because I think to myself,
I've got so much opportunity as guess what?
Oh I wake up and I'm,
I can walk around.
I don't have shrapnel in my back.
I get to eat food,
whatever you like.
Yeah.
Whatever you want.
They're like,
we like people complain about working out the complain like,
Oh I don't feel like working on,
what are you talking about?
I got a good idea.
Why don't you just be quiet?
Just stop.
People complained that they got to go to work.
Guess what?
You're blessed.
You're lucky you get to go to work.
You're lucky or thinking about that yesterday,
the working out thing.
Oh like people complain only cause my arm.
You know you have your situations that keep you from working out or training.
Yeah.
And on the up,
like did you check yourself when you get it?
Well,
it was a moment of appreciation what it was.
You know,
when you get,
you know,
you get injured or sick and you feel yourself getting better.
Like,
oh shoot like a mark.
You know,
like today I felt better than I've felt this whole time kind
of thing.
And that's when the,
the waves of appreciation,
you come back,
come back,
come back.
You know what the thing is also for those people that you know,
when you get an injury you think it's going to last forever.
This is what it feels like.
It feels like it last forever.
And then you realize when you get back you've kind of forget that it even
happened.
Yeah.
So yeah,
so the eating,
and that's a big part.
Every time that he mentioned eating,
we're starving or all the weight that he lost 88 pounds.
Yeah.
So that for whatever reason though,
that affects me a lot when I hear it.
And it's like,
Oh man,
cause you picture your biceps,
wouldn't he?
It makes you crushed.
Crushing.
Well,
you know just being hungry the whole time,
you know?
Yeah.
What's the longest you fasted for like 24 hours a day.
You need to get your 72 I dunno.
I Dunno.
That's cause you're saying for me cause cause being hungry goes away after a
little while now I haven't done,
I haven't done a hunger for 34 months.
Yeah.
Well it goes away like after like seven hours I think or subsides like to me in
my experience,
it depends on who you are,
I'm sure.
But at about four,
five hours,
that's when that's peak hunger in 10 but either way.
So you don't,
when he gets back like he gets,
you know they can't even believe it.
Wait,
just so everyone knows,
we are in no stretch of the,
any sort of imagination trying to compare a fast for 24 hours with 34 months,
34 months.
And I mean look at,
look at captain plumb six years and I don't know what Hilton eat no rice ball in
the morning and a rice ball in the evening with filled with wood chips.
What's up wood chips.
You know what,
you go to a restaurant right now if your rice is like slightly overcook your
complaining miss back.
Yeah nevermind bugs and wood chips in there.
Yeah,
no,
no it ships typically know.
Yeah,
it's um,
yeah that's,
that's rough to say the least.
But now you know,
and I look,
I'm living,
you know,
we're living kind of this journey with them in a small way.
Right.
And He,
the piece they come to,
you know,
peace agreement.
So he's back on the boat feeling the warm air eating three times a day,
man.
It makes you think like now,
okay,
what,
2018 right?
There's like more than one tooth.
There's many,
many apps on your phone that you can be like,
Hey,
I want a triple burger,
double cheese bacon,
I bacon,
avocado and you know what?
I will do onions,
grilled onions and I'm going to need that.
A grass fed
steak isn't quite good enough for me over here.
And by the way,
can I get the,
what's that special kind of Manet's that has like something else in it?
Well,
there's a few.
So it's called an AOL.
Lisa,
a old,
some of that.
All right.
Hey only man,
cause that's all other normal
man isn't quite in your,
you know,
you need to stop it.
We just don't want that one.
We don't want to,
you don't want to tell it.
We want the good ones so and so.
Let me go ahead and click this doctor.
So spoiled and then it comes to your door in about 15 minutes and he brings it
there and 15 minutes drive seven.
Even if it's 22 minutes,
you're kind of mad because that's like,
you know I was hungry.
Yeah,
you don't,
you know that.
And it'll say 10 to 22 minutes on the APP.
Like people,
people,
they get separated from their phone and they freak out.
Right?
I mean you imagine this,
like you would even know what's happening.
Anything in the world,
you know,
nothing.
You know nothing of what's happening in the world with your family.
Nothing.
Yeah.
So with this,
since other people have suffered through that maybe in in our world,
you can,
you can try and get yourself on a little bit better of a path of with a little
bit more discipline in the world is what I'm saying.
I know I need to step it up harder.
Did you more try and make more stuff happen because the opportunities there,
think about,
you know,
and the crazy thing is Richardson's one of the people that survived because
there's thousands upon thousands that didn't,
that died of diarrhea,
that died of dysentery,
that died of gangrene and infections.
Yeah.
So man,
we got it made so you know what?
We got it made.
So make something.
How's that sound?
We got made?
So make something of what you got,
which is everything,
which is everything by the way,
unless you're in the next to,
unless you're drowning in a trench full of shit.
108 pounds with no with your legs,
not working with scars in your back unless you're in that situation.
How about you step up into like just start moving in the right direction to a
little.
We're doing all right.
Yeah and and the helpful or what makes it helpful?
It's like perspective,
right?
When you put it into perspective,
let's say you live in your life every day year I'll use to it.
We're all used to it and you don't feel like doing something.
That's really what it,
what it comes down to.
And of course there's different levels of not feeling like doing something.
It's like kind of not feeling like this one or hey,
this is straight.
I'm not going to happen today.
Kind of feel it.
I feel like doing me.
So when you put it into perspective,
I don't know if you can like,
no,
it's to say not ours.
It's a non argument.
Exactly right.
Didn't even fly.
It doesn't hold zero water whatsoever.
Exactly.
Right.
You can't get to a place that you don't feel that.
You can't convince me ever that whatever you're saying is,
is even remotely weighs in on the situation at all ever.
Exactly.
Right.
That's where I don't want to get to know whatever.
Yeah.
When you know it needs to get done and you don't feel it.
Let's say up,
man,
I haven't in two days.
Let's say that that's legitimate in everyday life like man,
you get your rest row,
but if it needs to be done after you read this book,
let's say you didn't sleep because you read that book and you were just up for
two days,
you really don't feel like going to the gym.
I'll tell you that
physically,
but I like to leave just going and doing a bicep workout
or whatever you know or I hope,
I hope as a bare minimum,
I hope people use them.
The mindset you can pull from the,
from the perspective you get from this,
I hope at a bare minimum you get your workouts at the maximum hour,
will you step up and just take over the world because it's sitting there right
in front of you.
You're not locked behind Barb wire.
You don't have,
your arms are strong up behind your back and hung from the ceiling.
So painful that you pass out so painful that you pass out,
which that's just,
what does that even mean?
It means you can kind of do anything really when you,
when you kind of put it into perspective.
So what are we doing?
Me and Dave Burke,
good deal did.
Yes,
but you know,
we'll,
he's does reads a lot of books too.
And he just like,
man,
we didn't,
we just suck.
And we were just pathetic.
Yeah.
I can hear it.
I'm like,
yeah.
yeah,
it's just,
you can't even,
yeah,
I sent him a note.
I was wanting to know,
I was like,
you did,
hey,
you had combat,
um,
you did combat flights in Afghanistan and Iraq.
And he's like,
he's like,
Bro,
come on.
You know,
that's just come on.
And I'm like,
what?
He's like,
yeah,
Ted,
I technically did I drop bombs in those countries?
Yes.
Or where they considered a combat operations?
I'm like,
yeah.
And he's like,
but come on.
He's like,
he's like,
I got two words for you.
He,
whoa.
Gima and I was like,
all right,
I get it,
man.
But yeah,
that's,
that's how you feel when you get done in something like this.
And then by the way,
he's got a,
uh,
a one,
one half of a paragraph where he's like,
oh,
by the way,
I did 39 years in the army and by the way,
I was in Vietnam and by the way,
I was in charge of Project Delta for two times,
twice.
It's just like a little sub that's like a little,
little like just a little sub note,
a little ps look,
postscript.
Jeez.
Talk about that should be its own book.
Each one of those command tours is its own book about doing deep reconnaissance
into Vietnam.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah.
I didn't even make the cut.
Make the cut for the colonel and said,
Oh yeah,
no,
I talked about it.
I put up a paragraph in there.
Half a paragraph.
Yeah.
So he,
not only did he power through it,
he went back.
Yeah.
Jeez.
That's hit me.
And he did power through it by the way.
He did it like,
no,
he held on the line.
He didn't.
That part where he's talking about don't let them laugh at you.
Don't let them.
I underlined that and highlighted it and then I put stars by it because that's
the kind of thing that you think about.
Like,
like we know the world sometimes seems like it's having a joke with you.
Like it's like the joke is on you.
You ever wake up,
you're like,
the joke is on the joke's on me in the words and laughing at me.
Like that's not a good feeling,
right?
No.
Won't let that happen.
No,
you don't.
And Yeah,
thank you man.
See,
even keeping a sense of humor.
All this man.
So it's a humor.
Laughing.
That was a shitty situation.
Tuition.
Yes sir.
It was never.
Next time you think about something being shitty,
now you know what a true shitty situation is.
We all knew now we all now have a new definition of what a shitty situation is.
Standard.
That's the standard.
That's it.
That's where you're at.
So well,
yeah.
So we're on the path.
Like there's no one is off the path anymore.
We can't,
you're not allowed to just not even allowed on the path.
Right.
So when you,
when you started,
you did three,
if you have it all ready,
which most of us have.
Holy Cow.
Oh yeah.
It's like everyone that's thinking that's still on the fence,
right?
Just,
just get over the fence because every single person I know,
I won't say every single person there is a what percentage.
I've heard feedback,
I think from a total feedback of three people and it might only be two that
actually just didn't like it.
Jujitsu,
actually it's three,
one female,
two males,
the one,
the one male I went back and forth with for a while,
you know,
he was like hitting me up on Twitter.
This was pretty early on.
He's just like,
I just don't like it.
I'm like to perform grinding on me.
And,
and finally with that guy,
he just didn't want to do it,
man.
And I was like,
look,
do you know,
hey cool.
You don't want to ruin your life.
You don't make this into a living hell because you do something.
You did,
you fully hate.
It wasn't until the next guy that bitterly complained that I was like,
listen,
okay,
here's the plan.
Keep doing it until you submit someone.
Once you submit someone you can stop.
Yeah.
I didn't think of that plan yet until the guy number two and the other one who
was a female that it was two things,
uh,
didn't really like it but more important.
Didn't have anywhere to train and kind of just got off the path.
But yeah.
So uh,
but that's three out of many and many,
many,
many.
I mean most people are like,
oh yeah,
I'm obsessed now.
I'm obsessed.
Yeah.
Win or lose.
Like sometimes people will be like,
Hey,
I got beat up for hour and a half.
Well everyone says,
just went to my first Jujitsu class,
got choked 28 times by a 14 year old kid.
I love it.
If you've got your ego in check,
you say,
I love it.
If you don't got your ego in check,
you're like,
you know,
I don't know if this is for me.
I couldn't punch him.
Don't try and punch him.
Try and punch that 14 year old zoo at that triangle feels like then
cause it doesn't feel good.
Yeah.
People go hard.
And we ever had dean go hard on a triangle on you.
Like actually often,
authentically he did a triangle meat to me as he was just showing me something.
He locked that triangle up so tight.
I felt that in my lower back.
That doesn't even make sense.
It moved my spinal cord.
Yeah.
Don't,
I don't doubt it for sure,
but all right,
so we are doing Jujitsu.
That's Kinda,
that's kind of the deal.
Do you get,
what rash guard do you get?
Hey look,
there's plenty geese.
Plenty rash guards.
Not really all from origin.
There's only one.
Well the good news is,
and I was talking to some folks at the muster about this few times actually,
you know,
hey,
what gee should I get?
They're still asking that question.
That's the thing.
They already know the origin game.
Oh one G which should I get?
Get whatever one you want more advanced in our quest.
Yeah.
Because it's not the kind,
even if you get the,
you know how there's like levels,
if you even want to call them that will say price point,
if you will.
Like the Murrick some more expensive ones.
It's not the kind of where you get that and then you come in as a new white belt
and was like,
Ooh,
you're kind of flossing hard with that,
that you know.
No,
like if you get something like in wrestling,
if you were gold shoes and rusted,
that's exactly right.
It's not like that.
Or You dye your hair or,
yes.
Okay.
That's a little statement as a statement.
Yeah.
He's,
he's not like that orange hair.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm really good.
He's not like that.
No,
no sir.
He's just to get functional.
Yeah,
man.
You know,
maybe you know,
I don't,
obviously I don't go with Pete and Buehler courier.
Why are we doing this or this is per ticket,
so I don't know,
but I'm assuming maybe it took more to make certain ones or whatever,
but get,
get to the point is get whichever one you want.
Straight up,
lightweight,
heavyweight,
whatever from origin main.com.
True.
Also you got rash guards.
If,
if you want a rash guard then you can get a little git rash guard.
You got t shirts as well at from origin.
So basic like clothing and guess what we're we're making right now at this time
denim.
Yeah.
Oh I'm getting my,
I haven't gotten my pair yet,
but yeah,
we're making jeans.
So just be on standby.
It's going to take a little while to get that ramped up.
But it looked good though.
I saw pictures.
Oh yeah,
that's already posted them.
Yeah.
Yeah we will be.
We'll be making cause you know why?
Because everyone needs every human wears jeans.
Yeah.
Cause they're functional.
So every human needs genes and if everyone does then why not get jeans that are
made here made with the highest quality now all that stuff anyways,
so we have genes are common.
We also got some supplements.
Yup.
Jocko supplements.
So what joint warfare,
Krill oil discipline mark and where he could milk.
So what are these cover the most important elements?
I think of slop supplementation.
So joints,
those are going to go out on you.
That's it.
If you're into lifting heavy,
did Jujitsu hard you
into you work hard if you had like a manual labor type job?
Yup.
Moving company.
Yeah.
I know you are a mover.
I was American looser bouncer that that wasn't very hard.
I mean you'd have to work at all night.
Yes.
On your like feet and knees maybe depending.
But uh,
I would say,
you know,
just one year I would say the workouts,
the workouts get your joints.
I think especially over time,
especially if you're going very often.
And here's one of the things about the joint stuff.
A big part of it is you don't realize how much that,
how much benefit there is to taking krill oil and joint warfare on a regular
basis until you
yeah.
Well until or until you stop.
Oh yeah.
Big Time.
Which I haven't stopped.
I can't even answer that question.
But you've told us.
Yes.
So he had joy,
warfare,
Krill oil discipline.
Which discipline?
Like during the monster,
I drink a lot of discipline because like,
you know,
it's like go time the whole time.
Yeah.
So that's what now I'll tell you,
we got something else coming out.
We've got disciplined in little pills,
go pills and I'll tell you why.
I can't always pound right a bunch of discipline drink before.
Let's say I'm going out to speak sir.
I don't want to have to like hit the head in the middle of the speech because I
drink like a bottle of water right before I went out there.
So anyways,
I was like,
Hey,
can we make these things in little pills that I can take that can kind of get me
in the rock and roll mode real quick?
So yeah,
got those coming comments.
Not to mention you got to mix it up a big deal,
but if you're on the good,
good girl.
Yeah know.
So yeah,
discipline go,
go pills
common and they got a little bit of nootropic in them.
They've got a little bit of caffeine in them.
They had got a little bit of go,
you know,
a little bit too good.
That's the main ingredient,
the meeting ingredient.
Just go dig it.
Hey also,
okay,
so as we know,
the warrior kid mark is live and as we also know is tasting well.
It's live.
It was this morning I was,
I was making some strawberry milk for the kids for me,
but it's the kids mark and everyone in my house is freaking going nuts.
Everyone in my house is just drinking strawberry milk except for my youngest
daughter.
She's all about the chocolate.
But somebody took the milk scoop from the ward and like they was gone.
And this is where I realized there's something going on because I said to my
wife,
I said,
hey,
where's,
I said,
hey,
where's the scoop for the,
for the strawberry quick,
I actually called it strawberry quick because it tastes and now,
now I was talking to Brian and Brian's got Pete.
People are like notify gambit.
They're getting like putting the stall chick
memories of drinking Nestle's Quik cause that's where we're at.
The strawberry one,
the chocolate one doesn't taste as much,
like it tastes delicious but it doesn't taste the same.
Like whatever the quick like,
like exactly like quick does because that quick let's face it,
isn't,
isn't really that great,
but the strawberry quick is great.
Our chocolate is probably better than,
than the mass of these chocolate.
The strawberry quick is almost a replica.
And this is he legal to,
for me to say this is like comparing the brands or something like man,
okay.
Legal yet.
No,
no,
no.
All good.
And the nostalgia part that is,
that is something,
and I felt that too,
the one part then the SLG I used to get from the seven 11.
Yeah.
The strawberry quick from the seven 11.
We've got it from a store called big safe uncle.
But yeah,
that's for the protein and the regular milk.
That's for the protein.
So,
and so this is the other thing I wanted to say is as soon as I had the warrior
kids strawberry milk,
I texted Brian 14 seconds later,
it said,
make adult,
you know,
milk strawberry.
So it's in the works.
Um,
there's a couple,
there's you can't just say,
well I'll just double up because there's a little bit more protein in it in the,
you know you want to get a little bit more protein in the adult milk so that's
cool.
For those of you that are freaking out in the meantime,
take two scoops of two scoops of warrior kid mall.
Can you still do it?
All right.
Yes you are.
If you want to represent
the discipline equals freedom way,
whose discipline does equal freedom?
I think the more you grow up in life and embrace the discipline,
you understand that more because there are,
there are levels of understanding to the core to the core anyway.
If you want to represent,
go to Jocko store.com cause com has a store.
Which shirts on their hoodies?
Any,
any second now?
Hoodies,
Maura hoods or hoodies,
winter hoodies.
Well Michigan hoodies.
If your winter hoodies,
Minnesota,
potentially Hawaii.
They're not quite there.
Mainland,
mainland or at least we're in the mainland.
We are in the mainland in these cities for sure.
Maine.
What about my people?
Probably.
Yeah.
All right.
Anyway.
The point is,
is a lot of cool stuff on there.
I think it's cool.
DEF core difficult stuff to the car.
All things technically or def core.
Technically true.
I'm going to leave it at that.
Also,
hats on there and women's stuff.
Also rash guards too,
and the,
the hats are legit.
Yeah.
Truckers,
hats,
by the way,
does a year that are moral,
more old school in my opinion.
Truckers,
hats are more old school.
That's what I wore when I was a kid.
Truckers hats.
They come in and out though.
You know how they go out.
Then they come back in this style.
That's just the I've been wearing.
You didn't know about style.
Yeah.
I forgot.
Anyway,
flex it.
Hats on there as well.
A lot of good stuff.
If you want something,
get something.
Did we do represent while staying on the path?
There's some tea on the Doco t's on there and various other things.
Anyway,
take it off.
Jukka store.com yeah,
and if you want to,
you can subscribe to this podcast.
Why do we even say this?
Well,
I guess,
okay.
If you're listening right now and you've been listening for three freaking up
for,
I dunno,
three and a half hours.
If you're,
if you've done that,
go ahead and subscribe cause you're,
you're,
you definitely are part of the team.
You're in the game.
If you,
if you haven't heard,
if you haven't listened to this point,
well then guess what?
You're not going to subscribe because you don't want to subscribe.
So if you haven't subscribed and you hear the sounds coming out of my mouth
right now,
go ahead and subscribe iTunes,
Google,
play,
stitcher,
and then leave a little review action so we can,
uh,
have a good time with it.
And also don't forget about the war.
Your kid podcast,
the warrior kid podcast.
You can ask kids,
ask questions to uncle Jake and Uncle Jake tells stories about when he was a kid
and where he got his way from,
where he,
where he uncovered the way.
Also,
you've got the warrior kids soap from Irish oaks ranch.com.
Aiden's up there.
He's taken advantage of life.
Guess what?
You got goats.
You're in California.
You can't sell goat milk.
Guess what?
You can do make soap.
That's what Aiden's doing.
Young Aiden.
I was watching shark tank,
the entrepreneurship and you know,
there's a kid on there doing his thing and wasn't making respect.
Uh,
what was it?
Some glue,
some washable glue user using it for Legos,
which was kind of odd,
but I guess if you're anyone at lung,
but I thought it,
I thought about Aiden and the Jocko soap c eight and up there with chocolate
next to them or whatever you say all the time anyway.
And while you're in the subscribe mode,
then also subscribed to the,
the youtube channel,
the Jocko podcasts or youtube channel if you want to see echoes videos,
which he puts all kinds of time and effort into real super.
He gets super things that crazy about it.
It makes everything explode and then reflecting off of things as music,
cello,
music do.
So that's on the youtube channel and we've got some other things planned for the
youtube channel coming shortly.
Coming quickly.
We'll see.
I don't know if quickly is really a word that we used a lot back in Hawaii,
but you know,
we'll do our best and we're going to,
we're making it happen.
And then you got psychological warfare,
little little album with some tracks to kind of be pushed through some of those
moments of weakness where you're thinking you'd just want to eat that donut,
you don't need to know,
just don't need to.
So that'll help you out.
And we're also making a second psychological warfare album.
And if you want that then you can,
uh,
if you want to,
if he wants,
if you have a special request for that,
should I do some stop smoking cigarettes?
I've never smoked cigarettes.
I think you should at least do it.
And then
if it's like,
yeah,
cause I,
I would think,
but as far as potential problems,
you might run into like,
you know,
how like on the other ones like you can,
I get,
you can relate,
you know,
kind of what to say about it.
You know,
like,
hey,
you're thinking this or whatever.
Um,
yeah.
With the smoking.
Maybe you could compare it to something maybe felt that you might be addicted to
in the past,
but on an,
I think that's the whole,
that's a whole different game.
I'm pretty,
you know?
Yeah.
But I think again,
I think it's a different game to really like recruit tons and to be addicted to
smoking.
I don't know.
I've never smoked.
Well that,
yeah,
that's what that one's available.
Wherever you get mp3s,
iTunes,
Google play.
What
also,
if you're on the path working out,
that's part of it,
right?
My four things working out was wonderful and you want a very every workout.
So this is where you get your kettle bells on it.
On it.
Dot Tom.
Calm talk.
It's called on.com/jocko/jocko.
By the way,
get some rings.
Kettlebells,
Mace,
you got to the Macy's.
Dangerous.
If you don't know what you're doing.
So the goals that may seem like they're not heavy.
Yeah.
And you picked that thing up and you're like,
yeah,
big.
What's the big long thing with a ball in the end called?
Oh,
that's the mace.
No,
I'm thinking about the club.
The club bells bells are way more dangerous than the mace.
Yeah.
And that's what I'm saying where the club bells,
if you drop a club belt on your toe,
you will lose your toe.
Yeah.
And the work that should be called a tow remover.
If you are in a hospital,
then you were like,
oh,
you got a bad toe,
we're going to have to remove it.
Okay,
cool.
Come over here,
whack.
That thing's gone.
The club,
I like to work out barefoot sometimes.
Yeah.
And like you,
that's a dangerous proposition.
So be careful.
Just be,
yeah.
And really,
I mean a sane it,
it makes it sound like,
oh,
like almost more dangerous than it really.
Well,
my point is go on there and look at the workouts first.
Cause I've never done it and I still have all my toes.
I,
well I've never,
I've worked out with it a bunch and they still have all my toes.
So it's not that big of a deal.
But when you picked it up you're like,
Dang,
this is kind of it.
And then when you swing it and you're like,
Whoa,
let me get the smaller one.
Yeah,
well that's how it was anyway.
But anyway,
you can get that stuff.
Their rings are a big deal in my opinion.
Rings.
Yeah,
definitely.
You should have rings if you don't have rings to get them.
You see?
I said in my opinion like I just know about them.
Even though you were preaching rings from now I'm signed onto the rink.
How's the big stability muscles?
They're stable.
They're stable anyway.
Yeah.
I posted a picture of my son.
I don't really post that many pictures of my kids all the time or nothing like
that.
Every once in a while.
Sure.
But he was lifting.
You don't when you lift and it's like he just jumps in and says,
my attorney doesn't deadlift,
doesn't pretty good.
Kids have good form by the way.
Yes they do.
So he does a dead lift on one of the little on it.
Kettle bell is a smaller ones too.
Yeah,
and he's learned much.
Watch me.
He did.
Was a weight 18 pounds.
How much does he weigh?
I don't know,
18 pounds.
Here's a little light.
It was like he did it easy.
Well anyway,
I take it.
Why don't you get him a bit of color though?
He can start pushing the envelope or whatever.
But look,
we're not going to raise your kid to be reading.
No,
I'm just saying that's what he did at that time.
And I took a picture.
I mean I'm not saying we were maxing out,
me and my two year old maxing out dead lift and he only could do eight days.
That's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying.
Anyway,
I took a picture of it
so you can see it and it's,
and it has,
I looked at the picture and I can evaluate it.
I was like,
this is a good picture because it has like all the kettle know kind of scattered
about.
You framed it up.
Well technically,
I mean truth be told I was,
I'm making a video.
Oh,
okay.
Which may or may not have warrior kid themes.
Oh to it.
So while I was doing,
I picked that picture anyway,
it looks good on,
it was highly represented in that picture.
I liked it.
Let me tell you this.
Uh,
maybe if you would give your kid some Jocko white tea,
he would be able to deadlift more than 18 pounds.
He would might be able to deadlift 8,000 pounds.
In fact,
there's an actual guarantee because there's no age minimum requirement.
If you get that kid on the Jocko white tea,
there's the 800 pound deadlift.
Actually my girl drink two drinks,
legitimate drinks,
my wife's Jocko white tea and she dead lifted 8,000 barrels per yes.
Yup.
Proven hundred percent kids.
Everything Jocko white tea.
You can get the cams which are ready to drink or you can get the tea bags that
you have to boil water too big.
Oh God.
I don't want it to boil water.
And then that,
then you have to seek,
you have to seep it a what?
When you in the morning.
I don't drink uh,
Jocko white tea warm in the morning every morning.
But there's certain situ like at the muster.
Sure.
Oh,
I'm all about it.
And you know what his seat means?
Seat means you put the tea bag in there and you let it sit for a little while
and for some people they pull it out.
I just leave it in there the whole time.
You know Allen Allen stages.
Oh,
Ellen from monster,
Monster Allen.
He's stages.
He stays.
When I get up to the podium,
it's staged and I'm just like,
so what's good about that is it's,
I don't know,
in the morning time we just have a little warm while I guess it's hot,
technically is hot,
but I drink it warm.
Yeah,
I'm with you.
I don't know that there's a better beverage for that little morning little
morning scenario.
Yeah,
those a little mornings.
No,
just a little little cup of dark or white tea so you can get that.
Also,
I've got some books.
I got the way the warrior kid one end too,
and Mark's mission,
it's one and two.
It's the same series and those books I get more
incredible heartfelt feedback on those two books then I could have ever
imagined.
And it's awesome because kids can relate to the books and it is great for the
kids and it's great for the parents too.
And I get parents that just say,
this is making me a better parent because it's all just a big,
it's all just a covered move,
right?
I'm giving you this information here.
You get to flank your kid because your kids aren't going to listen to you.
Not 100% they'll listen to a little bit,
but they'll listen to someone that they,
some,
some other person that seems like kind of tough that they want to listen to.
Uncle Jake,
uncle Jake starts telling them what to do and they're down.
Totally dumb.
And Yeah,
so the warrior kid books one and two obviously get one first because it's a,
it's a story and it kind of continues and you need to grow and it's gonna
continue to grow.
We're going to see this,
we're going to see young mark all the way through through high school.
Right.
And Yeah.
So those books will help kids get on the path,
teach them about discipline,
to teach them about hard work,
teach them about eating right,
teach them about study habits,
teach them about taking responsibility.
It's like everything that a kid needs to know to be quite honest.
Where the red this is.
And this is kind of mean I guess in a way.
So I've worried kid to mark the mission on repeat in the household helps that
for my daughter's kindergarten,
they suggest like all these things that you should do every day and you can kind
of choose one and one is reading.
No,
there you go for a certain amount of time.
So I just read one chapter every single night,
every single night as punishment.
I won't though,
which is v pretty rare.
That's pretty awesome though.
Yeah.
All threaten.
Hey,
nope chapter tonight.
Ooh.
She scrambles to
fall in line.
Anyway.
Um,
so the good thing about having it on repeat,
cause obviously we finished or whatever.
I'm on round two like towards the end of the book and she just knows,
she knows that the answers now,
she's still excited about it.
But yeah,
because,
well now she knows.
So it's all familiar,
you know,
so she kind of knows.
It's almost like now she's,
I think she's,
that's amazing.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
So that's where the warrior kid and Mark Smith's get it for your kids.
Get it free.
Your neighbor's kids.
Get it for your kids across the streets kids.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Cause why not just help kids out?
Yeah.
And it does help.
What I'm what I was about to say about,
and I feel bad because one night,
this was like two nights ago,
um,
she got this new Unicorn Book Kids Book.
I don't know where she got it from school or something like this.
Oh yeah.
From their library,
whatever,
you know,
borrow the book.
Cause I had a new unicorn book.
Probably read that thing.
The thing is so lame.
It's a kindergarten level books by the way.
And so I'm reading it and I'm thinking this thing is lame.
I'm looking at her,
she's over there playing with Lego's while I'm reading and express.
She disengaged.
So quit.
It's some that just yet just,
she was just off that getting the word kid books back all day long.
Uh,
discipline equals freedom field manual.
This was cool at the muster.
A lot of people,
this,
this book definitely,
definitely hit people.
Hard.
Discipline equals freedom field manual.
So that book is a good,
you know what?
This book's going to be good for Christmas.
I know it's only what?
Thanksgiving,
Halloween.
Yeah,
but this book,
Christmas time,
this is the book you get for the the person,
you know who you need it for.
The person that needs to get a little a little help getting on the path.
So people read page a day,
two pages a day.
I read it,
I wrote it and I read it because it keeps you on the path.
So this one it goes freedom field manual.
Then you've got of course extreme ownership,
which I wrote with my brother Leif Babin,
which is just universally kind of become an accepted as a,
as a,
as a book that you need to read as a leader.
And that's followed up by the dichotomy of leadership,
which just came out,
both those books,
New York Times will sellers,
number one,
Wall Street Journal,
bestsellers,
both those books continuing to be almost less.
Why?
Because that's not through the big advertising campaign.
That's just through word of mouth.
People get it for themselves and they get it for their teammate,
then they get it up the chain of command down in the chain of command.
Get your,
get your,
uh,
get your team in the game with the dichotomy of leadership and,
and extreme ownership.
And then we got Mike and the dragons,
which comes out in November.
So here's what it's about.
Mikey young kid,
scared,
scared of everything,
finds a book.
The book that he finds,
it's called the dragon prince.
And he scared to read it because there's pictures of scary dragons in it.
But then he gets the courage to read it because he sees a little boy in there
too,
that kind of looks like he knows what's going on.
So he sees that little boy,
he goes,
I'm gonna read it.
So he reads the book and in the book the Dragon Prince,
there's the king,
his dad,
and the boy is now the only one that will defend the kingdom from the dragons
that are over the hill in the dragon cave.
And the boy is scared because he's only seven years old and just know what he's
gonna do.
It goes and finds his father's war chest,
pulls out the shield,
pulls out the sword,
they're too big for him,
and now he's even more scared.
But then he sees a note in the bottom of the war chest and he picks up the note
and here's what it says after he finds this note,
it says to my son,
if you are reading this now,
it means I am gone.
And you are the one that must carry on our kingdom is now what you must save.
And to do that,
you have to be brave.
I know that you think you don't know what to do,
but remember that I was once a little boy too.
I was also small and had fear in my heart and I didn't even know where to start.
I couldn't imagine going over the hill to face the dragons that wanted to kill.
But don't worry son,
you will be just fine if you can just keep these things in your mind.
And then he goes on to explain to him how he can overcome his fear of the
dragons.
And that's what this does.
The prince does,
the prince stands up to his fears and faces the dragons.
And then the boy Mikey learns from the lesson.
And you know,
we have to remember that we all have dragons to fight.
So when also remember that this book is coming out on Jocko publishing.
Hmm.
Why is that?
The big publishers couldn't get it out in time for kids to have it for
Christmas.
And that's what I,
once I had the book in my mind,
I wanted kids to have it by Christmas and the big publishers couldn't make it
happen because they're big,
they're big,
you know,
they got a lot of moving pieces.
We're nimble over here,
you know,
we're nimble.
So
since they couldn't get it out in time,
I had to kind of like,
they're a big dragon.
That's what they are true.
And so I had to kind of like stand up to the dragons and we can stand up to the
dragons in our own right with this,
with this book.
So if you want to help fight the dragons then grab a sword or at least grab a
copy and together we'll slay the dragons coming.
Also we got to have Salon Front leadership consultancy.
That's what we do.
We solve problems through leadership.
It's me,
it's the leaf is JP,
Dave Flynn,
Mike Cirelli and Mike Bye Mama.
Don't call a speaking agency to get us,
we won't do it.
Email echelon front or check the website echelon front.com or you can email
info@echelonfront.com the muster.
We just got done with the monster.
Good show,
good show.
It's awesome.
Awesome to be up there.
Awesome to meet all these people coming from all over the world.
South Africa,
New Zealand.
Right.
It's interesting this one woman came from New Zealand and like it didn't get a
shout out.
Lafe was kind of naming some of the countries where people from from and I don't
think,
well we didn't have it on the list or whatever.
We should have done a better job of screening it.
But she came up,
she was like,
I'm from New Zealand and I was like,
she goes,
I was like,
all that's awesome.
She goes,
you guys didn't say it.
I was like,
ah.
Now New Zealand was represented and it strongly,
and I signed a book.
She had to go,
she had to do a little like,
I think she did a coin flip to figure out who gets to go to the muster,
her husband she wants,
so I signed books for him.
So yeah,
come to the monster and the next one,
it just want be one in Chicago in the spring and one in Denver in the fall.
So it's looking like Australia in the winter,
so keep that on the down low.
But every,
every monster we've done is sold out and these are gonna sell out too.
So check extreme ownership.com if you want to get into that game.
Of course.
Now we also have EIF,
Overwatch,
a big subject.
Lots of people.
It's,
it's the war on the war for talent.
That's what it is.
Everyone needs good.
What if you have a problem in your world?
What's going to solve that problem?
Good leadership.
Where do you get good leaders from?
Well,
what we figured out is we get good leadership from the military,
so we got special operations and combat aviators that are ready to go out and do
work and we're putting them into companies that need leaders.
So if you've got a company or if you're a vet SPEC ops or or combat aviation,
go to eff Overwatch and you can get in the game there.
And if you want to continue this conversation that we're kind of having right
now,
you will spend kind of a long conversation,
but if you want to keep it going,
you can find us on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram,
and on Facebook.
Keep Echo is at echo.
Charles and I am at jockowillink and thanks to all of you for making this
podcast possible by all of you.
I mean,
first of all,
the military who protects our way of life and who sacrifice so much for our
freedom and our security and here at home,
police,
law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
key,
mts,
correctional officer's border,
patrol's first responders.
You know who you are.
Those of you in uniform.
Thank you for your service in protecting us here at home and everyone that
listens
wherever you are in whatever it is that you do.
Teachers,
investment bankers,
plumbers,
engineers,
electricians,
doctors and nurses and builders and bricklayers and everyone else that is out
there making their way.
Like I said earlier,
it can get hard sometimes.
That's the way life is.
And sometimes you can actually hear life laughing at you sometimes.
Okay.
But I say don't let it.
It's like when the Chinese guards conducted a mock execution on Colonel
Richardson and the other prisoners,
prisoners that he was there with,
and then the good the guards,
they stood there and they weren't laughing.
Yeah,
they were laughing at these terrified prisoners and the colonel,
he didn't like that at the time to master sergeant.
He didn't like that.
So he yelled,
he yelled,
get up.
Don't let them laugh at you.
Get up.
And I recommend that if you feel like the world is laughing at you,
you do the same.
You get up.
Yeah.
And get after it.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.